bonjour monsieur le Président bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté cette interview
merci de de prendre le temps aujourd'hui
c'est votre première interview
audiovisuelle depuis un petit peu plus
d'un mois c'était pendant l'été
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
notre travail est suivi par plusieurs
millions de jeunes et donc forcément on
voit au quotidien avec mon équipe avec
mon équipe de journalistes les
différents sujets qui reviennent souvent
les inquiétudes aussi qui sont très
présentes chez une partie des des jeunes
aujourd'hui on est un jour de rentrée on
va évidemment parler d'éducation mais
pas que on va parler de tout un tas de
sujets qui concernent notre générations
des sujets d'inégalité des sujets de
précarité des jeunes des sujets aussi
environnementaux forcément qui
concernent notamment notre génération
alors évidemment on pourra pas aborder
je le dis aussi pour ceux qui nous
regardent que soit en direct ou alors en
rediffusion on pourra pas aborder tous
les sujets aujourd'hui l'idée pour nous
c'est de faire un choix une sélection
sur les sujets qui nous paraissent les
plus importants au vu des retours qu'on
a pu qu'on a pu avoir et puis à partir
de là et bien on va faire en sorte de
creuser chacun de ces de ces sujets si
ça vous va on va pouvoir commencer du
coup tout de suite ça me va très bien je
suis à vous beaucoup de beaucoup de
sujets on va commencer tout de suite
avec un enjeu je pense qui nous concerne
qui nous concerne tous Aujourd'hui en
France selon les chiffre de santé
publique France un jeune sur 5 souffre
de troubles dépressif plus inquiétant
encore le nombre de tentatives de
suicide chez les jeunes atteint des
records plus encore d'ailleurs que
pendant le covid pour ne rien arranger
on a des services de psych batteries
aujourd'hui qui sont surchargé qui
appellent à l'aide face à une détresse
très importante des jeunes dans cette
situation on est la 7e puissance
économique mondiale selon les derniers
chiffres les moyens économiques
potentiels ils sont là ou ils pourraient
être là la santé le bien-être de la
population me semble et je pense qu'on
sera sûrement d'accord là-dessus être un
élément prioritaire pour un chef d'État
les chiffres pourtant sont sont
alarmants comment la situation peut-elle
être aussi grave
d'abord merci de commencer par ce sujet
qui je pense ne date pas d'hier c'est
beaucoup révélé pendant le covid on en a
parlé où je pense qu'il y a eu de la la
solitude beaucoup et moi j'ai été frappé
en tout cas même dans les débats ça ça
sortait beaucoup mais c'est là alors
est-ce qu'on dépense pas assez en terme
de santé dans notre pays non on est l'un
des pays qui dépense le plus et on l'a
beaucoup augmenté en sortie de covid
pour mieux payer nos médecins à
l'hôpital nos paramédicaux pour
réinvestir dans notre système c'est un
des enjeux pour moi des c'est une mes
priorités si jeis dire j'ai l'école la
santé l'écologie sont les trois
priorités en terme de justement de
service public dans le pays donc on
invest je sur 5 qui souffre de trouble
donc on donc
comment répondre à ce sujet d'abord un
diagnostiquer c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
a décidé cette rentrée on le systématise
de diagnostiquer tous les troubles pas
que santé mental mais entre autres donc
le diagnostic poser un diagnostic sur
des trouble c'est hyper important et
comment est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
auprès des étudiants les chiffres juste
là-dessus parce que c'est un des
éléments le diagnostiqu on est d'accord
donc on pe parler tout de suite
aujourd'hui il y a des études qui ont
été faites sur le nombre de psychologues
par université et par étudiants en
France on est à un psychologue pour
15000 étudiants de la universités c'est
10 fois moins que les recommandations
internationales sur le sujet alors le
deuxième problème qu'on a j'allis venir
c'est en effet qu'on a pas assez de
professionnel d'abord de psychiatrie
donc nous avons lancé ce travail on a
réinvesti dans ce sujet on est en train
de le faire on met 10 ans au moins à
former un psychiatre puisqueen fait
c'est un gen on va qui va faire des
années de médecine puis qui choisira
cette spécialité on fait tout aussi pour
revaloriser cette spécialité qui était
faut le dire aussi moins prise par les
jeunes qui sortaient de leurs études de
médecine et la psychiatrie aujourd'hui
est un des secteurs qui souffre le plus
dans nos hôpitaux comme dans le libéral
donc on a investi sur ce sujet on va
continuer de le faire et à la fin de du
travail qu'on a conduit sous mon premier
mandat on a décidé aussi d'ouvrir au
psychologues que vous avez parce que il
y avait en quelque sorte pas de lien
entre les deux donc maintenant on a créé
des forfaits tout particulièrement pour
nos étudiants qui quand ils ont
justement une telle souffrance ou de tel
trouble d'avoir la possibilité d'avoir
un forfait qui est remboursé par la
Sécurité Sociale de plusieurs heures
auprès d'un psychologue donc sur ce
sujet donc le sujet de la psychiatrie on
est d'accord et de la psychologie c'est
une nuance qui est d'ailleurs parfois
mal comprise et qui est importante à
faire le pyre est un médecin le
psychologue est un paramédical
exactement mais vous parlez de formation
de 10 ans ce que j'entends complètement
parceévidment le d'un psycholog qui le
cas d'un psychiatre voilà mais l'urgence
elle est maintenant elle est pas dans 10
ans on a des et remontter de la part de
d'hôpitaux d' psychiatriqu de services
qui disent qu'ils sont littéralement
débordés qu'ils mettent en danger des
jeunes parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
les moyens de faire correctement leur
métier d'abord sur la psychiatrie après
on parlera éventuellement des des
psychologues le besoin il est pas dans
10 ans il est maintenant comment est-ce
qu'on peut faire alors le BES première
chose si je reprends les choses dans le
bon ordre un diagnostic de de comprendre
comment cette situation se crée et
d'essayer de travailler sur la
prévention et elle se crée parce qu'il y
a du stress justement
chez des jeunes collégiens lycéens puis
étudiants parfois sur les questions
écologiques j'espère qu'on y reviendra
sur les questions d'avenir un manque de
bienveillance du système et donc il y a
tout ce qu'on doit faire et qu'on est en
train de développer pour mettre plus de
bienveillance dans notre système
scolaire et studiantin pour prévenir
cela TR il y a la prise en charge
médicale plus c'est pris en charge tôt
plus on arrive à encadrer on va pas
réussir à créer des psychiatres dans les
années qui viennent comme ça ça je vais
pas vous mentir donc on peut et donc
pour les services d'urgence et de
psychiatrie qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
l'immédiat donc ce qu'on la seule chose
qu'on peut faire c'est de consolider les
postes qui sont là c'est d'en former
davantage mais ça ça va prendre des
années et c'est de les aider à déléguer
des actes qu'ils font aujourd'hui dans
d'autres structures donc plus on s'y
prend tôt avec justement ce qu'on a fait
sur les psychologues plus on a des
jeunes qui ne tombent pas dans des
formes aigues et ne se retrouvent pas
dans les urgences psychiatriques plus on
développe des maisons des adolescents
qui permettent justement pour les jeunes
ou leurs famillees qui commencent à
avoir des troubles d'être accompagnés
plus on évite ça mais il n'y a pas de
solution miracle pour avoir d'un seul
coup plusieurs milliers de psychiatres
en plus dans notre pays parce qu'il faut
les former donc donc on est d'accord
psychiatrie et psychologie sur la
question de la psychiatrie ce que vous
dites c'est que dans l'immédiat il n'y
aura pas plus de moyens mis dans les
services de psychiatrie il y a des
moyens qui sont mis la difficulté c'est
de garder pour nous les médecins que
nous avons d'essayer de garder ceux qui
sont prêts à rester même en les gardant
on sait qu'on on fera pas donc a un
enjeu qui est important il y a un enjeu
qui est important c'est d'avoir un
continuum en fait ce que pour tout
quelle est la clé c'est de mieux
diagnostiquer de mieux prévenir et de
mieux nous organiser sur les formes les
plus aigues quel est le problème qu'on a
eu sur la santé mentale en particulier
des jeunes c'était un continent caché on
en parlait pas et donc on diagnostiquait
très mal on prévenait encore moins bien
et du coup on a eu des beaucoup de
jeunes et il y a eu un pic en covid et
après covid qui sont allés vers les
formes les plus aigues et donc ça ça a
complètement écrasé des services
d'urgence en terme en psychiatrie de
pédopsychiatrie aussi pour les plus
jeunes c'est un problème et la vérité
ils étaient déjà en souffrance parce
qu'il manquaient de professionnel donc
sur la psychiatrie on comprend que ce
sera une difficulté de fait pour les
prochaines années parce que il n'y a pas
de nouveauté qui sera annoncée dans ce
cadre là mais sur la question de la
maintenant de la prévention comme vous
dit alors juste pour être clair he on a
on a mis en on a monter des travaux en
2021 qui ont donné lieu à des
conclusions qui nous ont permis de
remettre de l'argent en formation et en
moyen sur la psychiatrie et le lien
entre psychiatre et psychologue comme je
le disais et là il y a un travail qui
est en cours pour la pédiatrie et entre
autres la santé mentale donc des enfants
et des adolescents sur lequel on va
mettre des moyens aussi parce que
pourquoi on a des étudiants qui à un
moment donné décompense c'est souvent
pour certains parce qu'ils avaient des
problèmes depuis plusieurs années qui
n'ont pas été détectés pas prise en
charge donc il y a la question des
psychiatres on a compris c'est des
études qui sont longues c'est des choses
qui prennent du temps à se à se mettre
en place en parallèle donc il a la
question des psychologues qui vous
l'avez dit sont dans un cadre différent
qui peut être présent notamment au sein
d'université ou autre pour justement
faire ce travail de prévention auprès
des étudiants mais ça peut être aussi le
cas pour les pour les enfants ce que je
disais à l'instant et et je me permet de
le dire parce que j'en ai parlé ce
weekend avec beaucoup de professionnels
de de ce secteur là pour comprendre ce
qu'il en était on est aujourd'hui à un
psychologue dans les universités pour
15000 étudiants c'est 10 fois moins que
ce qu'il faudrait selon les
recommandations internationales 10 fois
moins est-ce qu'on peut réellement faire
de la prévention qui est effectivement
essentielle si on manque aussi
cruellement de psychologue dans les
universités c'est-à-dire vous avez
parfaitement raison on a un sujet de
médecine scolaire et de médecine à
l'université h euh d'ailleurs si j'étais
complet je dirais aussi de médecine au
travail h et donc si on veut améliorer
la prévention on doit sur ce ouvrir ce
sujet parce que ce sont des professions
qui sont devenues moins attractives et
donc on n' pas assez de professionnels
et il travaille souvent dans un casadre
très difficile donc c'est ce que j'ai
demandé au ministre c'est un sujet qu'on
a ouvert là aussi pas covite sur lequel
qu on doit absolument s'améliorer
investir et donc comment est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui est prévu que je me per
d'ter une dernière fois c'est une
situation qui est urgente on parle de un
jeune sur 5 qui souffre de trou les
dépressif de d'ailleurs les chiffres
après le covid en matière de tentative
de suicide chez les chez les jeunes sont
particulièrement importante moi je le
vois c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
au vu du public et des retours qu'on a
c'est une situation qui est urgente
quelle mesure et compris sur les
psychologues comptez-vous mettre en
place sur les psychologues moi j'attends
le retour d'abord de ce qu'on a lancé
puisque il y a 2 ans quand vous étiez
étudiant que vous aviez un problème il
était mal diagnostiqué une fois qu'il
était diagnostiqué si vous alliez voir
un psychologue c'était de votre poche on
a mis en place un forfait qui fait que
maintenant quand vous allez voir un
psychologue et que vous avez un forfait
de 10h qui a été donné par votre médecin
référent qui peut être celui de
l'université ou votre médecin traitant
vous êtes remboursé de ce suivi ça c'est
une avancée qui est lié à la situation
que vous décrivez et donc là il faut
qu'on on est en train d'évaluer de voir
si ça commence à répondre au sujet
ça c'est le premier point visiblement
les chiffres sont pas très encourageants
dans ce cadre là parce qu'on est post
covid on est un an après le covid et les
chiffres sont encore pire que pendant le
covid c'est santé publique France dans
mon cas mais non santé publique France
il regarde le nombre de professionnels
rapportés à la à la population moi vous
parle taux de tentative de des nombres
de tentatives de Suou mais le le point
après c'est qu'il faut regarder comment
des systèmes qu'on vient de mettre en
place sont efficass ou pas par rapport à
ça donc après moi ce que je veux
regarder et ça c'est tout le travail
qu'on a lancé à avec les professionnels
c'est de regarder les causes elles sont
mul multifactorielles c'est qu'on voit
bien qu'on a un malêtre chez chez
beaucoup de nos jeunes qui est qui est
pas lié qu'à une cause tout n'est pas de
la santé mentale et là aussi il faut il
peut y avoir une anxiété qu'on narrive
pas à gérer il peut y avoir et donc
c'est un ensemble de sujets donc
certains relèvent de la santé et donc là
il faut pouvoir voir au mieux un
professionnel et ce qu'on doit
absolument améliorer c'est l'accès à un
professionnel de santé pour nos
étudiants et donc ça c'est tout le défi
de la médecine scolaire et de la
médecine à l'université qui est un
dossier que j'ai demandé d'ouvrir au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur donc là on aura
des travaux qui vont aboutir d'ici à la
fin de l'année et qui iront au-delà de
ce qu'on a déjà fait pour investir dans
la psychiatrie à l'hôpital et dans la
prise en charge des consultations auprès
de psychologu mais il faut regarder
aussi les causes profondes qu'est-ce qui
justifie qu'on a une génération qui a ce
mal-être tout ne relève pas de la santé
mentale on a des sujets de santé mental
il faut pouvoir les prendre le plus tôt
possible donc je reviens à mes sujets de
diagnostic et ça c'est des diagnostics
qu'on doit faire auprès des enfants et
des ados faut pas attendre que ce soit
des étudiants la deuxième chose c'est la
manière de gérer aussi les anxiétés de
la société ce qu'on voit poindre et ça
je reprends ce que beaucoup de
psychiatres de psychologues évoquent
c'est une capacité à gérer les messages
anxiogène qu' a tout tout au long de la
journée la société non mais et donc
d'apporter une réponse un cadre trème
point c'est la première génération aussi
qui a un rapport à la à la fois la
formation à laassociabilité qui est
totalement différente qui se fait
beaucoup par les réseaux sociaux par les
écrans ce qui change très profondément
le rapport à l'autre le rapport à
l'anxiété le rapport à la capacité à
gérer ses propres frustrations et ses
propres anxiétés et ça
tout ce que ce qui m'importe ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que c'est
exactement comme si on se disait face à
à des feux de forêt à l'issue d'une
campagne il faut que vous ayez beaucoup
plus de pompiers oui c'est ce qu'on fait
mais il faut se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi vous avez plus de feux
de forêt comment prévenir je pense que
les deux les deux enjeux sont les deux
enjeux se tiennent mais mon point je
voudrais pas qu'on regarde simplement le
curatif comme on dit pour moi ce qui est
au moins aussi important et même plus
important c'est comment on prévient
comment on arrive à détecter le plus
rapidement possible et comment on arrive
à traiter ces causes profondes du
mal-être de beaucoup de nos jeunes et
d'ù l'enjeu aussi du coup sur les
psychologues à l'université que qu'on
évoquit ex eu justement on va évoquer
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent une
parenthèse c'est vraiment et il faut le
commencer avant l'université c'est aussi
pour ça que j'insiste depuis tout à
l'heure sur
le diagnostic le plus précoce possible
et vraiment de suivre nos collégiens et
nos lycéens sur ce plan pardon on a
beaucoup de sujets qu'on va pouvoir
aborder ce soir celui-ci en est un et on
comprend que c'est un sujet qui a de
multiples facettes si je peux me
permettre ce terme là parce que ça
recouvre d'autres d'autres enjeux de
précarité ou autre un autre sujet qui
est qui me paraît essentiel et c'est pas
moi en l'occurrence c'est un consensus
scientifique dessus et c'est des retours
surtout de de nos abonnés sur le sujet
on a passé un été important avec des
records de température qui ont été
battus qui ont entraîné une sécheresse
et des incendies inédits en France mais
aussi beaucoup en Europe et d'ailleurs
dans le reste du monde aussi au Canada
avec ces incendies on a eu des corps
calcinés en Sicile ou en Grèce qui ont
été découverts de personnes qui n'ont
pas pu fuir ces incendies on a eu
évidemment un drame important en terme
de biodiversité dans ce cadre là l'an
dernier santé publique France a compté
7000 décès liés à la quinicule en 2022
en France l'urgence elle est là elle est
sous nos yeux et elle tue aujourd'hui
quelle nouvell mesure est-ce que vous
comptez mettre en place pour répondre à
cette urgence alors là aussi c'est un
peu la même chose il y a le il y a le
curatif et le
préventif face à ces urgences d'abord on
n pas attendu ces dernières années la
France fait partie des pays qui sont
parce qu'on a vécu rappelez-vous il y a
maintenant 20 ans une canicule qui avait
été terrible un été qui avait touché les
personnes âgées dans notre pays
exactement en 2003 qui avait eu des
conséquences absolument terribles donc
le système s'était beaucoup après
réorganisé et nous avons un des modèles
les plus efficaces pour lutter contre
les feux de forêt l'année dernière on a
eu une année terrible sur les feux de
forêt ce qui m'a conduit à prendre des
décisions là aussi de moyens on a
redéployé plus de moyens pour lutter
contre les feu de forêt dans notre pays
on l'a européanisé on a aussi mis
beaucoup plus de moyens pour prévenir et
mieux débroussailler et cetera ce qui
fait que on a eu un été très bien géré
en France en lien avec les collectivités
locales en lien avec les associations
tion qui débrossé et cetera et que la
France a été un contributeur de beaucoup
de pays européens et même au Canada où
on a envoyé beaucoup de nos sapeurs
pompiers mais ça c'est sur les incendies
sur l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est l'
environnemental non mais incendie comme
canicule c'est là et ça va être là pour
des années donc là on traite les
conséquences d'un réchauffement d'un
dérèglement même qui est là donc nos
sociétés c'est la partie ce qu'on
appelle l'adaptation donc là la France
doit s'organiser et nous nous organisons
donc on a remis beaucoup de moyens en
terme de sécurité civile ça a été une
très grosse augmentation ces dernières
années pour là aussi plus embaucher
mieux payer mieux équiper nos sapeurs
pompiers avoir le bon modèle territorial
la la réalité est là je touche du bois
parce que on va avoir des feux qui
commencent de plus en plus tôt et
jusqu'à plus en plus tard on résiste
bien et on aide nos partenire sur la
canicule sur la canicule c'est la même
manière c'est-à-dire qu'on est en train
d'adapter et ça c'est un énorme défi nos
nos établissements hospitaliers nos
épades pour les anciens nos écoles c'est
tout un plan que je lance et je
l'annoncerai demain on va faire un plan
de rénovation de nos bâtis scolaires en
lien avec les mères et là le but c'est
de rénover pour le bien-être de nos
enfants et nos enseignants mais de le
faire pour justement se protéger des
conséquences de la canicule et avoir des
bâtiments qui font face à des situations
thermiques qu'on connait aujourd'hui ça
c'est sur des conséquences qu'il faut
gérer les causes les causes c'est le
changement climatique alors ça c'est
tout le volet puisque vous partez de là
je dis nos sociétés doivent faire face à
ce qu'on appelle l'adaptation c'est un
investissement parce qu'on va vivre avec
c'est dérèglement après les causes
profondes c'est le réchauffement et donc
pour ça qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire on
doit réussir à moins émettre et mieux
préserver notre biodiversité le combat
jumeau c'est ça et sur ce point précis
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
mesures ce que l'on sait ce que disent
les scientifiques dans un consensus
quasi unanime c'est que même unanime
aujourd'hui c'est que ces épisodes qu'on
a vu l'an dernier qu'on a vu encore cet
été vont se reproduire vont
s'intensifier avec le changement
climatique donc l'enjeu il est bien là
on est d'accord là-dessus c'est l'enjeu
de prévenir en en luttant contre le
changement climatique est-ce que vous
avez des mesures de prévu dans les
prochaines semaines pour prévenir
justementoui alors c'est un ensemble
c'est la France c'est le chois que j'ai
fait l'engagement que j'avais pris va se
doter d'un plan d'ensemble d'abord ces
dernières années nous sommes revenus
dans notre trajectoire c'est-à-dire que
on a deux fois plus réduit que durant
les 5 années qui précédaient notre nos
émissions de CO2 la France on est dans
quelle situation on est parmi les pays
d'Europe qui ont le moins d'émission de
CO2 par habitant pour pourquoi parce
qu'en fait on a parmi les pays
développés parmi les pays développés oui
pourquoi parce qu'on est pas sinon on
est parmi les pays les plus pollueurs au
monde alors quand on regarde les choses
dans l'historique c'est tout à fait vrai
parce qu'il y a eu la révolution
industrielle la France parce qu'elle a
opté pour le nucléaire pour produire son
énergie et que le nucléaire représente
un peu plus de 70 % de la source de
production d'électricité et bien produit
son énergie en émettant en utilisant et
en émettant beaucoup moins de carbone
que les autres bon donc je le dis juste
par rapport à nos voisins on est nous
avec les pays du nord de l'Europe ceux
qui produisons le moins de CO2 par
habitant maintenant quel est notre
objectif c'est de le réduire
drastiquement d'ici à 2030 et d'arriver
à la neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 donc
ça c'est la planification écologique qui
a été présentée à l'ensemble des
associations et des ONG à l'été qui va
être présenté par la première ministre
au forces politiques dans quelques jours
et qu'on va déployer et pour est-ce
qu'on est sur le droit chemin selon vous
si on fait cette planification oui mais
c'est pas un chemin spontané comment
est-ce que vous expliquez que le Haut
Conseil pour le climat que vous avez
créé en 2018 pour justement évaluer
votre stratégie et la stratégie du
gouvernement sur le climat et bien cette
même instance il y a encore quelques
semaines c'était tout récent c'était au
mois de juin il me semble fin juin le
rapport a été remis à Elizabeth born
estime que et bien certes il y a des
évolutions mais ces évolutions elles
vont beaucoup beaucoup trop lentement
pour s'en sortir ne pas foncer dans le
mur c'est sur la base de leur analyse
qu'on va présenter la planification qui
arrive et pour vous représenter les
choses J jusqu'à 2018 2000 201328 on a
baissé un certain rythme qui était
insuffisant
ensuite les 5 ans qui ont suivi on a été
deux fois plus vite et ben les 5 ans qui
viennent qui sont devant nous faut aller
encore deux fois plus vite 2,5 fois plus
vite sel donc je vous confirme que il
faut complètement changer de vitesse et
la nature de nos efforts et donc pour ça
il y a pas une solution unique et
miracle il faut porter l'effort dans
tous les domaines donc de manière très
simple qu'est-ce qu'on va faire un il
faut électrifier les pratiques
et donc partout où on utilise du fossile
faut passer à l'électrique parce que
nous on a une chance c'est que notre
électrique comme je le disaisie on
produit pas avec du carbone ça pas de
sens dans les pays où on fait de
l'électricité avec du charbon c'est pas
le cas chez nous et justement très bon
exemple si vous le permettez sur la
question des mesures qui pevent être
mais sur la question de par que vous
parlez de l'énergie vous parlez des
transports c'est effectivement un enjeu
de sortir des énergies fossiles pour
aller notamment sur l'électrique parce
que comme vous le dites on émet peu de
CO2 aujourd'hui en France parce qu'on il
y a le nucléaire l'énergie nucléaire qui
permet de ne pas euh produire trop de de
CO2 sur ce sujet très précisément je
pense que c'est un bon exemple de
mesures qui pourrait être mise en place
et qui sont revenus dans les les
questions de des abonnés donc je me
permets de la de la poser en Allemagne
depuis le 1er mai je pense que vous
l'avez suivi pour 49 € par mois en plus
des métros des bus et cetera vous avez
accès pour 49 € par mois à tous les
trains en illimité tous les trains de
région hors TGV et pour le reste tous
les trains c'est un immense succès il y
a plus de 7 millions d'abonnés à ce à ce
service là on voit que c'est quelque
chose qui encourage finalement les
personnes à délaisser l'avion
typiquement qui évidemment éimet
beaucoup plus de CO2 au profit du train
de de créer des sortes de de ouais de
vacances alternatives si on peut dire ça
comme ça qui forcément sont moins
coûteuses et donc aussi plus
intéressantes est-ce que ce genre de
mesure vous comptez le mettre en place
en France alors oui alors je suis
simplement revenu parce que c'est un
ensemble beaucoup plus large c'est pas
avec une mesure comme ça qu'on règle le
problème du tout mais c'est un exemple
parce que à la fois c'est large donc
détail je pense que c'est important de
se donner après les masses pour voir où
sont les taux d'effort parce que souvent
dans ce débat je le dis on s'est perdu
sur des des micro exemples et on a perdu
le la la photo d'ensemble et et les
vrais points d'effortê temp quand trop l
aller con non non mais moi jeer dans le
concret surtout vous inquiétez pas je
suis avec vousant que vous voulez donc
je vais vous dire un oui j'y suis
favorable et j'ai demandé au ministre
des Transports de lancer avec toutes les
régions qui sont prêtes à le faire le
même dispositif le la la la réalité chez
nous c'est que c'est les régions qui ont
la tarification de leur billets qui font
leur billets toutes les régions qui sont
prêtes à le faire avec l'État banco on
là il y a un tour de table avec les
régions et si c'est le cas on aura un
service similaire en France dans les
prochains mois le ministre des
Transports comme la première ministre
porte cette idée de la première ministre
l'a annoncé on met en place un passtrain
pour tous les jeunes qui se mettent au
service national universel au service
civique pour pouvoir justement utiliser
le train beaucoup plus simplement et tr
on a surtout acté cette décision partout
on avait des lignes de TGV là qui qui
explique de faciliter le transfert modal
et de plutôt passer à l'avion vers le
train en fermant certaines lignes
d'aviation si on regarde je prends deux
pas de recul parce qu'il y a des trucs
très concrets qu'on va faire qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on va moins aimettre de CO2
et préserver la biodiversité parce que
les deux combats je veux pas qu'on perde
de vue la biodiversité qui est aussi
importante parce que les forêts sont des
puits de carbone et des trésors de
biodiversité comme nos océans et Forêts
océans sont deux très grands combats
pour pour nous qu'on porte au national
et l'international nous qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire on doit donner le coup
d'accélérateur sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments on a fait un
million de rénovation thermique et donc
là dans la planification on va lancer de
nouveaux instruments et aider à
accélérer et intensifier cet effort sur
l'innovation termique qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire encourager tous ceux qui
peuvent à faire des travaux sous quelle
forme c'est nouvelle alors c'est des
aides c'est simplifier les aides et
c'est les accroître et la deuxième chose
c'est mettre des contraintes à certains
propriétaires qui ont des logements qui
sont plus du tout en état où il y a
énormément de gaspillage énergétique
parce que c'est à la fois pas écologique
et pas juste les gens qui vivent
dépensent beaucoup et donc au moment où
ils les vendent ou ils changent de
locataire de devoir faire les travaux
pour faire ce changement donc là il y a
tout un travail sur le logement qui est
à faire avec là aussi des innovations
qui permettent de le faire beaucoup
moins de manière beaucoup moins coûteuse
qu'avant deuxième point c'est développer
massivement et ça j reviendrait les
pompes à chaleur qui sont un instrument
qui à côté de l'électrification de
manière très concrète donc on veut
développer un système et une filière
française de pompe à chaleur déployer
leur mise en œuvre parce que c'est
quelque chose qui permet justement de
réduire la consommation et de réduire
les émissions de CO2 3 c'est les
transports et les transports vous l'avez
très bien dit le but c'est d'aller vers
plus de transports collectifs en
particulier dans les zones urbaines et
ça dans quelques semaines je présenterai
un peu la carte des projets qu'on a
retenu c'est les fameux RER
métropolitains c'est de se dire dans nos
métropole certains dont commencé
d'autres sont plus en retard il y a des
différences on met le paquet pour
investir et pour déployer justement des
réseaux électriques parfois avec des
connexions
hydrogène pour justement avoir des
connexions et faciliter bah l'abandon du
véhicule individuel aller vers le
collectif avoir une politique
préférenciel en terme de tarification et
inciter tous les habitants à se déplacer
par ces solutions qui seront in une
question très claire sur ce sur ce
pointl une question toute même sur la
question des transports vous vous le
savez évidemment sur la question des
voitures par exemple on a des bonus des
malus qui existent de la même façon
aujourd'hui sur les transports en commun
alors si on peut utiliser le terme de
transport en commun les trains et
l'avion le ressenti aujourd'hui c'est
pas qu'un ressenti c'est que sur
certaines destinations le train coûte
plus cher que l'avion en plus de ça
souvent il est plus long alors ça peut
être plus confortable parce que c'est
plus sympa de partir depuis le le
centreville ou autre mais ça coûte plus
cher souvent et c'est plus long et je
parle de bonus malus parce queil y a
aussi un ressenti que et bien l'avion
finalement est une forme de mode de
transport épargné par rapport au train
c'est-à-dire que typiquement l'avion le
kérosè n'est pas taxé c'est quelque
chose qui a été appliqué dans d'autres
pays certains pays ont appliqué une
taxation sur le kérosè sur les vols
nationaux parce que c'est est autorisé
on peut le faire sur les vols nationaux
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il n'y a pas de
taxation sur le kerosen alors qu'on sait
que l'avion est infiniment plus polluant
que le train ou d' d'abord la France est
un des pays qui taxe le plus son
aviation je pense qu'il faut pas se
tromper quand on dit ça mais sur le
kéosen non mais la la la vérité c'est
que on veut avoir un système qui reste
on peut le bouger si on le bouge au
moins à l'échelle européenne voire
internationale bon la deuxième chose
c'est que aujourd'hui nous on crée
toutes les incitations on a fermé
certaines lignes c'est une des
conséquences de la exactement et donc ça
c'est un point qu'on évolue troisème
chose nous on a mis en place la taxe
pour les billets d'avion pour financer
le développement et donc on a on taxe
justement nos acteurs on va taxer aussi
les concession aéroportuaire ça va
retomber sur les compagnies donc ce
serait faux de dire que aujourd'hui il y
a un avantage fiscal pour les acteurs de
l'aviation il y a même la France taxe
plus que beaucoup d'autres voisins son
son aviation derrière ça comment on
explique qu'on termine avec un billet de
train qui est beaucoup plus cher qu'un
billet d'avion et que et ça peut
comprendre quand on est le billet
d'avion s'il y avait qu'un seul acteur
il serait aussi cher que le billet de
train ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a
eu des économies très différentes
pendant des années qu'on a des des
acteurs lowcost qui sont rentrés dans le
système de l'aviation et qui sont venus
casser les prix sur certains billets
mais l'État peut réguler non mais on
régule mais on est on est une économie
ouverte et que du côté mais peut régul
tout attendez et que du côté du
transport ferroviaire il y avait pas de
réforme et pas d'ouverture là il y a une
petite révolution ferroviaire qui est en
train de se faire d'abord on a changé le
système ferroviaire on l'a modernisé
c'est la réforme de 2018 il y a eu des
grves j'ai eu beaucoup de critiques mais
j'entends tous les gens qui disent il
faut aller vers le ferroviaire c'est
aussi beaucoup de gens qui ont jamais eu
le courage de réformer le système alors
le système ferroviaire pourquoi c'était
cher parce qu'on faisait pas de réforme
parce qu'on avait un système de retraite
qui objectivement était plus soutenable
parce qu'on avait un système qui était
pas efficace donc on peut pas dire d'un
côté je défends un système inefficace
mais je suis pour l'écologie non donc
moi je suis cohérent c'est pas c'est pas
mon cas mais non non non je dis pas vous
mais je dis beaucoup de commentair c'est
une question qui rient souvent qui est
très concrè juste moi je suis cohérent
moi je suis cohérent le système
l'aviation il y a un acteur français qui
est a France il a été concurrencé par
beaucoup de lowcost ce qui crée la
situation que vous évoquez on a régulé
mais jusqu'à un certain point et la
France a plus taxé que ses voisins les
billets d'avion maintenant pourquoi il y
a ce différentiel parce que du côté du
ferroviaire il y avait beaucoup moins de
concurrence et un acteur qui était pas
assez efficace on a fait la réforme de
la SNCF on est plus efficace on a des
cheminau qui sont formidablement engagés
dans cette transition on va aller vers
du mieux en mieux on investit sur les
infrastructures pourquoi ça marchait
moins bien c'était plus cher parce que
pendant des décennies on avait
sous-investi sur les infrastructures
ferroviaires depuis 2018 on réinvestit
massivement en parallèle on a encore du
boulot là-dessus ça c'est la
responsabilité de l'État pas des régions
à côté de ça on veut unifier avoir une
politique tarifaire mieux veillante
mieux mieux disante c'est ce qu'on va
faire avec les régions en allant vers un
passe un tarif unifié et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on doit qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire justement derrière si on veut
être cohérent aussi c'est permettre à
d'autres acteurs qui sont moins chers on
a certaines lunes qui sont ouvertes à
d'autres acteurs européens qui sont
parfois moins cher et qui arrivve sur
notre réseau et qui rendent le train
attractif je voudrais juste ajouter un
point qu'est-ce qu'on fait en par par
allèle de tout ça il y a une
responsabilité beaucoup de gens se
disent je préfère prendre le train à
mesure qu'on fait ses réformes ça
devient ça se rapproche ceux qui ont le
moyen de le faire essaie de le faire oui
mais on rapproche de plus en plus mais
en parallèle il faut décarboner
l'aviation parce que on on prendra
toujours des avions et objectivement en
plus nous en France est-ce qu'on prendra
autant à l'avenir est-ce qu'on prendra
forcément autant à l'avenir l'avion nous
en France produit beaucoup d'avion et
moi je serai un drôle de président à
vous dire ça aujourd'hui alors que nous
sommes un des champions de
l'aéronautique et que nous produisons je
crois environ enfin une bonne partie de
de de de la flotte internationale d' un
point non négligeable et qu'on a des
grands champions et qu'on a des emplois
partout en France sur ce sujet donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait non mais attendez
sur ce point une question qui est très
simple qui qui est qui me paraît
centrale dans ce sujet c'est que
j'entends que la l'aviation est un
élément important en France qu'on a des
des on
a mais l'enjeu là-dessus est-ce que
réellement pour des raisons économiques
on doit continuer à encourager une
industrie qui de fait pollue infiniment
plus que d'autres modes de trans
décarbon c'est ce qu'on fait pour toutes
les industries d'abordous nous dans
notre usage qu'est-ce qu'on va tous
faire et ça c'est ça la transition un on
va on va se poser des questions qu'on ne
se posait pas avant est-ce que j'ai
vraiment besoin de faire ça et c'est les
comportements qu'on appelle de sobriété
ou d'économie d'énergie il y a de toute
façon pas de transition s'il y a pas ce
premier bloc clair deuxième point dans
la transition on doit là aussi
décarboner et donc la bataille c'est
dans cette industrie et la France va le
faire dans d'autres industries les
championns on décarbone et donc on
investit beaucoup d'argent donc comment
on fait pour que l'avion pollue moins à
court terme on fait de l'innovation et
on allège justement le poids des avions
on change la motorisation c'est ce qu'on
fait avec nos grands acteurs comme
safran j'ai été visité il y a quelques
mois et on change la nature des
carburants avec ce qu'on appelle non
attendez c'est très concret ce que je
disais maintenant hein oui mais mais ce
que disent les scientifiques aujourd'hui
ce que disent et je me permets pour ça
de le dire ce que disent l'intégralité
des scientifiques aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on ne peut pas attendre une
innovation d'un point vue de l'avation
pour s'en sortir il
faut il est là que je suis en train de
vous dire c'est ce qu'on fait là c'est
pas une innovation l'enjeu c'est qu'on
réduise no C je relis simplement ce que
disent les scientifiques sur le sujet ce
que disent les scientifiques le rapport
du je le ha conseil sur le climat c'est
que il y a peut-être une modernisation
qui est possible on est d'accord de
l'aviation il a sûrement des progrès
déjà qui sont en cours pour autant ce
que disent l'intégralité des
scientifiques sur le sujet c'est que ça
ne suffit pas et qu'il faut baisser
progressivement uation de l'aviation un
consensus scientifique ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que on peut parler après
de la planète là je suis sur la France
sur la planète non mais on peut agir en
France bien sûr mais c'est ce qu'on fait
et on agit massivement et et nous on est
sur notre trajectoire et on va tenir nos
objectifs grâce à cette planification en
désouant c'est totalement faux de dire
si nous on faisait ça simplement en
franco-français si les autres ne le font
pas donc c'est un effort mondial mais
nous qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire je
reviens à l'industrie aéronautique si on
veut réduire les émissions un faut des
avions plus légers c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire de faut des moteurs qui
consomment moins ou qui à performance
égale consomme moins ou qui se
transforment pour moins émettre c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire c'est les
moteurs qu'on développe aujourd'hui 3
faut changer le carburant et donc on est
en train progressivement de sortir du du
kérosène et entre maintenant et 2030
quel est notre objectif c'est d'intégrer
progressivement ce qu'on appelle les SAF
qui sont donc nos carburants durables
qu'on met dans les avions avec le kérosè
et de de passer d'ici à 2030 à 50 % de
SAF 4 ensuite c'est de passer à l'avion
hydrogène électrique et donc oui on est
en train de faire ces innovations et ça
c'est du post 2030 donc il y a une
courbe sur l'aviation et donc mais il y
a un enjeu de réduction de l'utilisation
même de l'avion falloir qu' passe au
sujet suivant parce qu'autrement on y va
pour non mais c'est hyper important mais
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
que la France elle a un plan ce plan on
l'a présenté début juillet il va être
présenté au f politique et moi je vous
le présenterai là dans quelques semaines
ce plan il touche tous les secteurs et
c'est faux de dire si on se fait très
mal sur un secteur on va y arriver tout
seul non la France c'est 1 % des
émissions mondiales on va faire notre
part et il se trouve que nous qui
émettons moins de CO2 par habitant que
beaucoup d'autres pays européens on
tient notre part ce que ne font pas no
voisin on ne remplit pas les objectifs
que les scientifiques rempl pardon à
date on les remplit on est en retard
selon les scientifiques non les
scientifiques nous disent si vous voulez
remplir sur les 5 années à venir vous
devez faire plus que dou plus
votre'estce que je vous dis je suis
hyper transparent je dire moi je vous
l'avez dit vous-même j'ai créé une
instance pour évaluer et elle dit que
c'est insuffisant mais parce qu'elle
nous dit si vous voulez réussir en 2030
c'est pour ça bien que je que je me
fatigue à faire un plan là je suis pas
en train de vous dire qu'on continue
pareil mais donc c'est le logement c'est
le train c'est aller vers plus de
véhicules hybride et électrique et donc
c'est la la révolution de la voiture
c'est l'avion et là je là où je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous faut un
peu réduire la consommation faut
beaucoup moderniser donc c'est un
ensemble mais c'est pas simplement dire
on va tous arrêter de prendre l'avion
moi je suis pas là-dessus d'autres que
je respecte beaucoup sont là-dessus
c'est pas mon cas c'est décarboner notre
industrie on sait que l'industrie c'est
une part non négligeable de l' des
émissions on en a parlé un peu pour
l'aviation mais les ciment et C là on a
lancé un très grand plan et on a dit les
principau sites poll émetteur et bien on
décarbone et on les fait passer du gaz
ou du charbon à l'hydrogène et cetera et
on y va je me permets de passer parce
que on est on a passé plus la
moitiéinterview sur une thématique il en
reste plusieurs je voudrais qu'on les AB
j r Dom 2 secondes cette affaire très
rapidement pour qu'on pue abut suj qui
sont aussi important c'est que nous on
se
bat et je crois je pense c'est un combat
générationnel et c'est notre
responsabilité et je vous le dis on sera
au rendez-vous de nos résultats et ça va
demander un effort à tout le monde mais
il faut que l'effort soi proportionné
faut que chacun comprenne l'effort que
fait l'autre donc personne sera exemp de
la transition la France c'est à peu près
1 % des émissions nous on fera notre
effort si on veut que la planète s'en
sorte c'est plus que ça si on prend en
compte les importations mais faut faut
non vous avez raison non mais ce qui est
très important de comprendre c'est où
est le cœur de la bataille en
internationale parce qu'on fait partie
des pays leader sur ce sujet le cœur de
la bataille c'est quoi la sortie du
charbon la sortie du pétrole si on
arrive à ce que les grands émergents
sortent du charbon une bonne partie de
la bagarre est gagnée et donc moi j'ai
un objectif et je reprends les termes du
Haut Conseil pour le climat et sa
présidente charbon 2030 pétrole 2040
2045 si on arrive et nous là on va se
mettre sur cette agenda d'ici à la fin
de l'année à aller sur cet objectif nous
on y arrivera pour le charbon grâce
justement au renouvelable et au nucléire
et on va se mettre en place pour le
faire sur le pétrole ce qui est un très
gros effort sur le plastique et Surut ch
tard je me permet de H important le
sujet et donc faut pas faut pas sortir
de faut pas juste perdre de vue qu'on a
cet immense objectif charbon pétrole
pour les les décennies qui vienn dès
maintenant et qu'on va le porter à
l'international et que la France est
leader sur l'agenda forêt et océan on a
lancé le One forest suit qui est clé
pour la biodiversité le carbone et pour
protéger les forêts primaires parce que
tout ce que je suis en train de dire
pour la France bien sûr ne vaut pas si
on laisse déforester l'Amazonie le
bassin du feuou la forêt des du
sudest Océ parce que je je je vois que
le temps fil j'ai passé beaucoup plus de
temps que ce que j'avais prévu
initialement sur ce sujet là en même
temps il me paraît essentiel je pense
que vous serez d'accord
surè justement c'est pour ça c'était on
a passé beaucoup de temps sur sur ce
sujet d'environnement qui mine de rien
est un sujet important très sur la
rentrée on rentre sur la question de la
rentrée effectivement on est le lundi 4
septembre jour de rentrée mais avant
même de parler de la rentrée on va
parler plus de rythme scolaire et donc
peut-être un petit peu de la question
des vacances si vous le voulez bien
pendant un instant en effet il y a eu un
certain nombre de déc déclarations
pardon qui ont été faites ces derniers
jours et ces derniers mois un sujet
important c'est la question des vacances
d'été vous avez évoqué une idée d'une
refonte des vacances d'été est-ce que
les prochaines vacances d'été dans les
années à venir ou d'ici la fin de votre
ququena seront plus courtes que celles
que l'on connaîit aujourd'hui alors
d'abord ça ça doit se concerter mais moi
je souhaite qu'on ouvre cette question
des vacances ou plutôt du du temps
scolaire dans l'année l'école ça sert à
passer des on y reviendra mais c'est
quoi la mission de l'école c'est hyper
important transmettre des
savoirs transmettre un esprit critique
des valeurs faire des républicains et
donner la confiance permettre de
travailler et acquérir se faisant donc à
mes yeux aussi faire du sport des
activités artistiques et cetera quand on
regarde la France on a des programmes
plutôt chargés par rapport au voisins
mais je compte pas les alléger parce que
on veut revenir aux fondamentaux et
remettre plus de fondamentaux et mieux
les évaluer parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
trop de jeunes qui arrivent en trop
d'enfants qui arrivent en CM2 qui savent
pas assez lire écrire compter du coup
ils arrivent en 6e ils se perdent c'est
là qu'on a le décrochage scolaire
simplement est-ce qu'on a les meilleures
conditions pour apprendre la réalité
c'est non parce qu'en fait on concentre
le le temps scolaire sur quelques jours
et on a pe faire du 8h 18h en une
journée ou fa que on a moins de sport
d'activités éducative d'activités pardon
artistique or c'est très bon pour le
développement pour la confiance en soi
et on apprend mieux et à l'inverse on a
des vacances même je vois par rapport
vous êtes beaucoup plus jeune que moi
mais moi quand j'étais à l'école on
avait pas de semaines à la toussin on
avait pas de semaines à pâac on a accru
toutes ces vacances intercalaires et on
a des vacances d'été qui sont beaucoup
plus longues que les copains et surtout
en fait qui sont plus longues que ce
qu'on dit parce que la vérité c'est
comme le le le brevet des collèges
puilbac sont organisés souvent dans
l'établissement Cour juin et pas début
juillet en général mijuin ça juin que
ceux qui ont vraiment l'école complète
enfin le collège ou le lycée complet
lève le doigt je peux PL je peux pler
coupablep'est- qu'on veut faire donc moi
qu'est-ce que je dis je veux qu'on que
nos enfants et nos adolescents
apprennent mieux donc on doit ouvrir ce
sujet donc j'ai dit au ministre et c'est
pas qu'un sujet vacances pour ça que je
remets en perspective c'est une question
de rythme de de de de la vie étudiante
premier sujet immense sujet que je veux
dire pour les parents et les jeunes qui
nous écoutent le sujet remplacement dans
l' on va parler on va parler
dansant donc moi je pense qu'il faut
repenser les vacances et le temps pour
pouvoir avoir plus de temps de sport de
culture de repos et de devoir dans
l'année quelle forme ça peut prendre on
a juste làdessus sur ce sujet on a des
modèles en Allemagne par exemple où
effectivement TR c'est des modèles
attractifs un modèle que vous aimeriez
voir en France le modèle comme
l'Allemagne où globalement quiment
demour pour ça que moi je pense que
c'est un système qui doit se parler qui
doit se discuter au plus près du terrain
mais je pense qu'il faut ouvrir ce sujet
ça doit pas être un tabou que le sujet
des vacances est un sujet si on pour
apprendre mieux qu' doit être ouvert que
c'est ce qui permet aussi à nos
enseignants parfois d'avoir moins de
stress faut faut faut se faut mesurer
que les enseignants il y a souvent
beaucoup de caricatures qui sont faites
préparer les cours corriger les copies
c'est beaucoup de travail les
enseignants ne travaillent pas que dans
le temps devant les élèves et donc ça
leur prend aussi beaucoup de temps si on
leur permettait de mieux travailler dans
l'année c'est ce serait à mon avis mieux
mais surtout les élèves apprendrai mieux
si on repensait ça dire une chose on
parlait d'inégalité on va en parler
aussi les grandes vacances c'est la pire
des
inégalités parce que quand vous êtes
d'une famille qui vous fait faire de
devoirs de vacances qui a une
bibliothèque à la maison qui vous fait
faire du sport qui vous envoie ENAC en
en voyage linguistique à l'étranger vous
revenez en septembre vous êtes super
prêt quand vous êtes d'une famille
pauvre qui peut pas partir en vacances
dans un quartier où il y a pas
d'infrastructure sportive vous revenez
vous êtes généralement crevé vous avez
passé des mauvaises vacances et vous
avez désappris et ce qui fait que vous
avez on regarde ça a été mesuré parce
que vous me parlez beaucoup d'études à
juste titre vous partez des faits moi
aussi un jeune d'un quartier populaire
il revient au 1er septembre il a pas son
niveau du 1er juillet il a génér son
niveau de fin mai Mii c'est la pire des
injustices c'est pour ça que je dis
quand on a des évaluations difficiles ou
autres il faut peut-être pouvoir rentrer
un peu plus tôt très rapidement
là-dessus pour comprendre un peu votre
vision sur sur le sujet ce que ça veut
dire j'entends que c'est pas un sujet
seulement de vacances évidemment il y a
les vacances mais il y a aussi du coup
les cours il un sujet de réorganisation
du temps scolaire pour faire en sorte
d'avoir des journées qui sont
différentes pour visualiser un petit peu
ce que vous ce que vous imaginez je sais
que c'est des concertations mais ce que
vous avez un modèle que vous avez en
tête c'est quoi dans l'idéal selon vous
la journée d'un jeune au collège ou au
lycée c'est le matin jusqu'en début
d'après-midi en cours et l'après-midi de
la culture je pas faire de modèle unique
d'abord je vais vous dire le modèle que
je vois c'est un modèle où chaque élève
à l'école primaire ce qu'on a maintenant
mis en place fait au moins une
demi-heure de sport par jour moi
j'espère demain 1 heure comment est-ce
qu'on fait en sorte d'y arriver parce
que une heure de sport c'est aussi que
ce soit d'ailleurs dans le cadre des des
cours rur des cours c'est mais on le
fait tout honnêtement si on fait ce que
je suis en train de dire là on a
largement la place et je pense que ce
faisant qu'est-ce qu'on apprend avec le
sport pour ça que moi j'y crois à fond
donc là on a mis la demi-heure donc
demi-heure dans le en primaire on fait 2
heures de plus au collège en utilisant
le temps périscolaire et on fait le test
en 6e l'évaluation justement sportive
conditions sportive pourquoi j'y crois à
fond 1 c'est quand on fait du sport on
est bien 2 c'est un formidable
instrument pour mieux apprendre parce
que quand on est un élève dissipé un peu
hyperactif quand on aime pas l'école on
arrive le matin bon bon courage pour
commencer les matths à 8h ou 8h30 les
finlandais l'ont fait très bien moi je
dis je regarde ce qui marche ailleurs il
y a des il y a des il y a des endroits
la classe les élèves sont calmes pas
besoin de faire des sports le matin faut
en faire l'après-midi d'autres vous leur
faites faire une demi-heure même de
balle au prisonniers ou une demi-heure
de rugby puisqu'on a le Mondial qui la
Coupe du Monde qui commence en fin de
semaine et ben je peux vous dire qu'ils
apprendront les males l'heure d'après
vachement mieux donc le sport ça aide à
mieux apprendre tris c'est un instrument
de santé on parlait justement de
prévenir le sport c'est un instrument de
santé ça prévient la l'obésité avec la
santé mentale vous avez commencé par là
c'était une un formidable sujet un
continent et on est encore très loin d'
répondre vous l'avez bien mesuré et je
mesure le défi pour moi un autre immense
problème de santé publique pour nos ados
et nos jeunes c'est
l'obésité nos jeunes c'est aussi la
conséquence des écrans par rapport à il
y a 20 ans sont malheureusement de plus
en plus obèse c'est le sport la
politique de prévention et ça permet de
de justement d'éviter des tas de
maladies et plutôt que se dire dans 10
ans quand votre successeur interrogera
mon successeur il y a pas assez de
spécialiste encore là je sais pas vous
vous serez encore là moi non donc vous
avez raison de me dire
ça vous interrogerez mon successeur et
vous direz mais pourquoi vous avez pas
assez de médecin pour encadrer l'obésité
ou le diabète des jeunes j'espère qu'il
pourra vous dire on a moins justement
d'obèse donc ça c'est le sport et puis
ça donne un cadre moi je suis frappé il
y a des tat jeunes qui ont pas assez de
cadre le sport en donne un donc moi
comment je vois pour moi c'est très
flexible le système ça doit être il faut
qu'il ait je voudrais qu'il ait à terme
1 heure de sport par jour en primaire au
moins autant en collège je voudrais
qu'on ait des jeunes qui aient la
possibilité d'avoir une pratique
culturelle tous quelques heures
justement par semaine le pasculture
avait été annoncé le passculture est
entendu dès la 6e mais que l'éducation
artistique et culturelle entre dès
l'école primaire et que donc ce soit pas
des extra des activités périscolaires
qui dépendent du choix de la famille
même si les mairies font un formidable
boulot sur ce sujet qu'on a des
conservatoires des écoles de danse de
spectacles et d'art vivant partout en
France c'est une nos force mais que ça
soit dans l'école et que ce faisant on a
une un temps scolaire qui soit Enel plus
souple et qui parce qu'on a plus de
semaines d'écooles de collèges et de
lycées dans l'année pu intégrer du sport
de l'éducation artistique et culturel et
le temps de devoir et d'accompagnement
parce que ce sera une école où on
apprend mieux et qui est plus juste sur
la question de l'école donc là on a
parler du temps scolaire et on entend
votre vision sur le sujet on verra du
coup quelle forme ça peut prendre dans
les prochaines années actuellement un
autre sujet évidemment qui est beaucoup
revenu aujourd'hui on va pas passer
énormément de temps dessus mais ça me
paraît quand même important de revenir
dessus c'est la question de laaba
laabaya qui est donc interdite dans les
écoles depuis la rentrée la rentrée
pardon ça a été confirmé par le ministre
de l'éducation nationale Gabriel Atal
c'est un sujet qui concerne quelques
centaines d'établissements sur plus de
59000 établissements aujourd'hui et une
question qui est beaucoup revenue dans
les commentaires lorsque j'ai annoncé
l'interview hier c'est la question de
savoir au-delà d'ailleurs du débat sur
l'interdiction le choix d'annoncer une
telle chose au journal de 20h alors
qu'on est une veille de rentrée qui a
énormément d'enjeux on a commencé à en
voir quelques-uns qui sont présents le
choix d'en faire une telle annonce quand
on sait que ça va provoquer autant de
débats autant de réactions et peut-être
masquer d'autres sujets qui concernent
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de monde c'est
évidemment un sujet mais l'enjeu c'était
la question de notamment de la façon don
ça c'est bah vous avez raison mais qui
de la fou de la poule il faut y répondre
il faut y répondre clairement ça peut
être différemment que en faisant un GT
de 20h pour l'annoncer on sait quand on
fait ça en Gén pas se sujet du ministre
20h mais il a été clair et je l'en
félicite je vais vous dire en France
l'école elle est gratuite laïque est
obligatoire laïque ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que nos enfants on veut pas
savoir d'où ils viennent ce qu'ils
pensent de quelle famille ils sont c'est
c'est un élément de justice parce que ce
sont des des républiques et des citoyens
con forme et donc de la maternelle
jusqu'au baccalauréat l'école et laïque
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas la place
pour les signes religieux et je pense
que c'est très important et vous avez
dans not ça été vécu comme une forme de
stigmatisation al au-delà du débat sur
caractère religieux de d'atenu ça a été
vécu comme stigmatisation par vous me
connaissez je suis pas je suis je ne
stigmatise personne c'est pas mes c'est
pas c'est pas des sujets sur lesquels je
je montre du doigt je suis pour tous les
enfants de la républi soi dans l'éco la
façon don ça a été ressenti par beaucoup
de jeunes les gens qui poussent la BAA
c'est c'est pardon ça peutê ça peut-être
un choix aussi de certaines personnes
par c'est un choix religieux c'est un
choix qui convie quelque chose qui est
un le fait de dire moi je suis différent
et je viens dans cette école comme ça je
le regrette moi je veux je pense que ça
a été très bien fait par les les
directeurs d'établissement les
enseignants ce matin faut discuter faut
expliquer mais je pense que c'est très
important parce que l'école doit rester
ce lieu neutre je sais pas quelle est
votre religion vous ne savez pas quelle
est la mienne après quand on est
étudiant on peut remettre un signe
religieux parce que les consciences sont
forgé mais c'est très important et c'est
pour ça que d'abord moi j'ai assumé en
2020 de fermer des écoles qui sortaient
du système scolaire les enfants et qui
en quelque sorte les ramenaient à leur
conditions donc on a les écoles qui
étaient très stigmatisantes justement
elles et qui sortaient bien souvent des
fillettes de notre système scolaire on
les a fermé tout le monde doit être dans
le système scolaire public privé sous
contrat privé hors contrat mais on doit
respecter dans l'école publique ce
principe qui est important de laïcité je
pense qu' ça fa dans le respect dans la
bienveillance donc moi je par je pense
que un le ministre a eu raison d'être
clair pourquoi parce que on peut pas
faire comme si on vivait dans un pays où
la question était apaisée parce que si
on n'est pas clair au niveau national ce
sont les enseignants et les directeurs
d'établissements qui sont renvoyés avec
la pression sur le terrain donc il faut
les protéger parce que sinon on dit pas
de vague et on laisse s'installer des
défis à la licité la loi n'est pas
respecté dansjeux dans les enjeuxite de
moi je pense que c'est pas le sujet le
plus important c'est un sujet où faut
être intraitable et clair et on le sera
maintenant il faut que tout le monde s'y
range et que ce soit respecté faut que
les familles qui voulaient mettre la BAA
pour leurs filles ou les jeunes filles
qui voulaient la mettre comprennent ce
pourquoi on le fait c'est respectueux
c'est bienveillant c'est la laïcité
française on ne vous empêche pas de
croire à une religion mais dans l'école
il y a pas de place pour ces signes le
cœur de la bataille c'est comment on
apprend mieux on transmet les valeurs on
fait des républains et très rapidement
là-dessus parce qu'on a vu quand même
que le débat était très très présent et
chaque année globalement en fait la
question des vêtements revient à la
rentrée cette année c'est la question de
la BAA l'an dernier c'était la question
du crop top donc un t-shirt court vous
aviez déclaré au magazine l je cite que
tout ce qui vous renvoie à une identité
une volonté de choquer ou d'exister n'a
pas sa place à
l'école au passage c'est quasi
systématiquement la question de de des
tenues des femmes qui revientent quand
même souvent sur ces sur ces débats là
en général qu'est-ce que c'est dans ce
cas une bonne tenue pour aller à l'école
bah c'est alors ça c'est pas le
président la République qui disent qu'il
y a une bonne tenue il y a des règles
qui sont fixées par le gouvernement mais
je réagissais là un problème de société
là pour le coup sur la laïcité c'est le
président de la République qui en est le
garant parce que nous sommes une
République laïque après c'est les chefs
d'établissement ont cette possibilité
dans chaque établissement il y a des il
a il y a des règlements et donc faut s'y
conformer et donc je renvoie là pour le
coup a des zones mais non mais non c'est
et que il y a des déclarations du coup
qui reviennent oui mais si vous vou
c'estz pour ça que moi je pense que
c'est une bonne chose que ce soit au
niveau de l'établissement vous avez des
établissements les parents mettent leurs
enfants dans établissement il se
conformment aux règles ça n pas été cas
là c'est le gouvernement qui a dit pour
tous les établissements VO règ parce que
les chefs d'établissements à juste titre
ont dit la pression est trop grosse sur
nous on a des parents qui nous défient
on a des gens qui veulent en fait qui
testent la laïcité faut pas se tromper
nous vivons dans nos sociétés aussi avec
une minorité mais de gens qui détournant
une religion viennent défier la
République et la laïcité et et pardon
mais ça a parfois donné le pire on peut
pas faire comme s'il y avait pas eu
l'attaque terroriste et et l'assassinat
de Samel pati dans notre pays et ça
c'est fait mais là on parle d'une on
parle de laba on ne parle pas de non
mais je ne fais aucun mais je dis juste
ce système est là et ça c'est fait parce
qu'un
enseignant apprenait la laïcité dans son
cours et qu'ensuite il y a eu cet
emballement avec les réseaux sociaux et
des gens qui ont ensuite commis le
pire on va pas rentrer dans ce débat là
parce que la Baya est réellement
forcément ce ce la façon dont vous le
voyez ici c'est un parallèle qui est bah
qui je pense fait fait beaucoup peut
faire débats je fais aucun parallèle moi
le parallèle entre la BAA et et
l'assassinat de Samuel en parallèle je
vous dis juste que la question de la
laïcité dans notre école est une
question profonde et que est-ce que je
l'ai mise en avant en vous parlant de
l'école non je pense que l'école est un
sujet éminemment important pour
transmettre les savoirs nos enseignants
apprennent aussi des valeurs dont la
laïcité et le cadre c'est la laïcité et
que je n'en fais pas moi un principe que
je je brandis je dis juste aujourd'hui
vous avez une minorité de gens vous
l'avez très bien dit il y a environ 500
établissements qui sont les plus soumis
à cette pression mais que si le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et moi en
répondant à votre question aujourd'hui
n'est pas clair et courageux le risque
c'est que s'installe l'impression en
France qu'en quelque sorte nous
abandonnons les professeurs aux
avant-postes et que c'est eux qui sont
en charge de ça et vous avez des
professeurs dans notre pays qui quand
ils enseignent la laïcité l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière c'est ça la
possibilité le droit de caricature et
autres se font alors attaquer jusqu'au
pire et je vous dis juste je vous
rappelle juste que dans mon premier
quinkena c'était pas il y a très
longtemps c'est arrivé et le pire est
arrivé donc ça existe donc il y a des
gens qui sont capables du pire dans
notre pays donc on doit rien céder faut
pas généraliser on a des millions de
gens qui veulent vivre en paix dans
notre pays je moi je suis pour la
bienveillance et la tranquillité et donc
je pense que le ministre a eu raison
d'être clair on doit être intraitable on
doit expliquer concerter mais on doit
pas non plus cacher la poussière sous le
tapis un dernier sujet sur la question
du vêtement et après il y en a il y a
1000 autres sujets à aller à aller
évoquer donc on on va essayer de
d'avancer mais je suis conscient que
c'est des sujets qui sont importants et
qui méritent aussi qu'on prenne le temps
donc on en a parlé ici sur la question
du vêtement une dernière question
certains proposent le retour de
l'uniforme ça ne vous aura pas échappé
Gabriel Atal donc le ministre de
l'éducation nationale est favorable à
des expérimentations il a d'ailleurs
déclaré ce matin sur RTL qu'il allait
mettre en place des expérimentations
dans les prochaines semaines ou à
l'automne il me semble donc on suivra
tout ça en 2017 vous aviez déclaré
réfléchir à cette question vous n'aviez
pas de position arrêtée sur la question
de l'uniforme
aujourd'hui prètisisons après est-ce que
vous avez évolué quelle est votre
position aujourd'hui sur le port de
l'uniforme à l'école moi je suis pour
être comme vous l'avez dit d'abord ça
prend une des proportions folles bon moi
j'étais plutôt pour que chaque
établissement gère la chose et donc je
suis plutôt pour on regarde et qu'on
expériment alors il y a l'uniforme il y
a aussi la la tenue unique sans avoir un
uniforme on peut dire vous vous mettez
en jeans t-shirt et veste je vous
regarde non mais c'est c'est pas un
uniforme moi ça me va j'aurais pas grand
chose à faire voilà
et et donc non mais je veux dire par là
on peut avoir tout à fait des choses qui
sont beaucoup plus acceptables aussi
pour les adolescents la question de la
tenue unique qui n'est pas l'uniforme
qui a mon avis est plus acceptable peut
paraître un peu moins strict d'un point
de vue disciplinaire elle règle beaucoup
de sujets parce qu'au fond qu'est-ce que
vous voulez quel est le sujet à chaque
fois qu'il y a derrière c'est un la
laïcité et deux un peu l'idée qu'on se
fait de la dcence c'est-à-dire on veut
pas d tenu trop excentrique on a tous
connu ça on a tous parfois vécu on
mettait les les dernières baskets et on
se faisait refouler à la porte de
l'établissement parce que chef
d'établissement avait dit pas basket bon
donc moi je trouve que l'approche c'est
ce que j'ai dit au ministre quand on en
a parlé au début de l'été moi je suis
favorable à l'approche expérimentation
évaluation j'étais plutôt favorable à
l'approche par établissement je constate
qu'il y a une telle pression sur ce
sujet sur les chefs d'établissement que
expérimenter évaluer permettra
d'éclairer le débat public donc il y a
des expérimentations à l'onne et on
verra on verra ce que ce que donne là je
vous rejoins qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
à l'école je dire tout ça il faut le
remettre dans un contexte
apaisé parce que ce que ça avec quoi
vous avez commencé est
juste très juste l'école ça construit du
commun c'est pour faire des citoyens des
républicains faut que N et on veut que
nos gamins soient bien et donc
construire du commun et c'est pour ça
qu'on transmet la même langue les mêmes
savoirs les mêmes c'est avoir un espace
où il y a le moins de différence
possible et donc je pense que l'objectif
qu'on vise il faut un certain bon sens
faut sortir des débats qui divisent et
moi c'est aussi pour ça que je ne veux
pas que les enfants de confession
musulmanes se sentent exclus ou mal à
l'aise à l'école je ne veut pas que les
enfants ou les adolescentes qui
voudraient mettre telle tenue se sentent
exclus ou mal à l'aise à l'école fut une
forme de bon sens derrière tout ça ce
qu'on veut faire l'objectif de la nation
c'est au fond qu' a rien qui vous exclut
et qui vous sépare et donc un on veut
éviter les tenues qui vous renvoient à
une religion parce que ça vous exclut ça
vous sépare et que ça ne vous met pas
dans un cadre commun et c'est la laïcité
de on vous on veut éviter des les
situations qui mettent un peu de la
stigmatisation sociale et donc moins on
a de débat sur les marques mieux c'est
trois on veut éviter les tenues trop
excentriques qui qui qui qui provoque
d'où les expérimentations et on suivra à
l'automne voilàir derrière faut sortir
des débats microcosmiques et dire bien
sûr c'est construire du commun parce
qu'on doit être tous ensemble dans la
même c'est un sujet plus large c'est
pour ça aussi que je m'étais permis
d'évoquer rapidement la question de
l'uniforme à la fin de de cette question
sur la BAA autre sujet sur lequel on va
avancer c'est la question du harcèlement
un autre sujet évidemment très très
important on l'a vu encore une fois dans
les retours que soit sur Youtube ou
Instagram ces derniers jours ça a été
aussi beaucoup dans l'actualité pour des
tristes événements en mai dernier lin
une adolescente de 13 ans s'est suicidée
après avoir subi une vague de
harcèlement au collège et sur les
réseaux sociaux elle avait pourtant
dénoncé justement ce harcèlement dont
elle était victime dès la rentrée de
septembre 2022 et sa famille avait
déposé deux plaintes au mois de février
et avait aussi averti la direction la
direction pardon de son de son collège
et là je parle ici du cas de lins mais
vous l'avez suivi je pour aussi parler
des cas respectivement de Lucas ou
encore de de
thba il y a un dispos disitif qui
s'appelle le dispositif phare qui a été
lancé par le gouvernement contre le
harcèlement scolaire ce dispositif il
était en place au sein du au sein de
cette de cette école du collège de Linc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
pour être entendu bon d'abord sur le cas
de Linc j'ai une vraiment une une pensée
affectueuse pour pour toute sa famille
c'est maman qui a vu mon épouse et qui
va voir d'ailleurs le le ministre
bientôt et ils ont vécu ce qu'il y a de
pire qui perd un enfant qui met fin un
séjour après une telle situation je je
veux pas rentrer dans le détail de la
situation parce qu'il y a des enquêtes
en cours et des procédures multiples
mais vous avez ce que vous dites est
factuel il y avait eu des démarches il y
avait eu des réponses de l'école et et
des premières mesures qui se sont
avérées insuffisante et le dispositif
phare était là c'est un combat
absolument essentiel si on veut que nos
enfants d'abord soient bien à l'école
puissent bien apprendre et et en effet
parce que c'est le harcèlement peut être
à la cause de beaucoup de choses le pire
le suicide le décrochage scolaire dans
certains cas ou après le le mal-être
trouble et et et les situations qu'on
décrivait au début de nos discussions
donc c'est une cause absolue donc
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire un le
programme PHARE faut le renforcer
renforcer renforcer son effectivité il
est là on forme les enseignants on les
sensibilise mais faut s'assurer de
manière systématique que la réponse elle
est proportionnée suivie et qu'ellecout
donc le système n'est jamais parfait et
donc sans relâche sans relâche à cet
égard je pense qu'on est en train de le
renforcer avec des référents je remercie
là aussi les enseignants les
responsables de vie scolairire dans les
établissements les chefs d'établissement
mais aussi on a mis en place des
délégués donc les les élèves mêmes sont
un peu responsabilisés sur ce sujet plus
généralement c'est un peu une question
d'état d'esprit je disais dans les
objectifs de l'école il y a transmettre
les savoirs l'esprit critique et il y a
la confiance on a besoin d'avoir une
école plus
bienveillante et ça c'est un point
essentiel sur tous les sujets de société
à côté de ça on a nos dispositifs ce
qu'on met en place dès cette rentrée qui
je pense dans quelques-uns des cas que
vous avveit évoqué mais je veux pas
faire par cas peut changer beaucoup de
choses c'est d'éloigner l'élève qui
harcèle quelle était la situation qu'on
avait souvent il y avait des sanctions
elles étaient elles pouvaient être une
exclusion quelques jours des retenus
mais c'est la personne victime qui était
sou exactement c'était la l'élève
harcelé qui finissait par changer
d'établisement c'est inversé et donc là
maintenant ce qu'on fait on prend tout
de suite la décision et on éloigne et on
met un dispositif de suivi sur l'élève
qui a harcelé ça je pense que c'est très
important et c'est un changement complet
d'approche qu'on fait et puis à côté de
ça donc un on renforce phare je pense
que tous les enseignants maintenant ont
conscience mais on renforce la
sensibilisation on a mis des équipes
dédiées on met l'éloignement de l'élève
qui harcèle et puis à côté faut
renforcer le cyberhcèlement parce que
dans tous les cas que vous avez évoqué
c'est pas qu'un harcèlement à l'école
c'est que ça compte continue et ça
continue sur les boucles WhatsApp ça
continue sur le facebook ça continue sur
le TikTok ça continue sur les instas et
Cera plus TikTok que plus des réseau des
jeunes Facebook est moins utilisé par
les gour' non non je bien pardon mais je
veux être cuménique parce queil y en a
qui c'est absolument tous ces réseaux il
y a TikTok il insta il y a les boucl
faut pas oublier il y a pas que réseau
il boucl un enjeu de cyberhcèlement donc
sur le cyberhcèlement là aussi on a eu
un très gros boulot qui a été fait avec
des des associations harcèlement et
cetera on a le 38 qui a été mis en place
et donc là on est en train de passer une
loi qui cet automne va être votée qui va
permettre maintenant si je puis dire
d'éloigner en ligne les
cyberhceleurs en les interdisant de
réseau pendant 6 mois et si c'est s'il
reproduisent pendant 12 mois et ça je
pense c'est aussi une mesure très
importante parce que ça c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas été fait
jusqu'ici en France donc pour bien
comprendre c'est l'idée de faire en
sorte qu'une personne auteur autrice de
cyberharcelllement qui est signalé
puisse être après un signalement
qu'est-ce que elle n'est plus présente
sur les réseaux donc la loi va mettre
une procédure en place qui est permis
grâce au justement aux directives
européennes en particulier DSA que nous
avons mis en place et qu'on transcrit
dans la loi française donc la loi
française va mettre en place une
procédure qui va permettre contre les
auteurs de cyberhcèlement et bien de les
éloigner si je puis dire des réseaux et
de leur possibilité d'agir sur ces
réseaux ils ont cyberharcelé pendant les
6 mois qui suivent et et ça concerne les
jeunes les adultes tout le monde et pour
bien comprendre dans ce dans ce cadre là
du coup la forme que ça prend parce que
c'est finalement ce que vous faites
semble
ici l'idée du coup d'éloigner les
personnes qui font des actes de
cyberhcèlement quelle que soit la la
forme pour bien comprendre qui va
décider de cet éloignement est-ce que
c'est la justice est-ce que c'est le
réseau social est-ce que c'est comment
est-ce que cette décision je ne veux pas
préamer ce que les ce que les ce que le
législateur va faire mais ce qu'on
propose en effet c'est que sur la base
de de une procédure graduée c'est que le
juge puisse tout tout à fait le faire
mais que quand il y a des procédures de
de signalement et quand les autorités
compétentes le signalent au réseau ils
puissent aussi le décider si je résume
pour ceux qui compris qui nous qui nous
rejoignent c'est une mesure qui n'existe
pas encore aujourd'hui que vous allez
porter et donc on verra si est si est
voter mais votre objectif c'est de faire
en sorte que des personnes hauteur
autrice de harcèlement puissent être
éloigné des réseaux sociaux en cas de
condamnation par par la justice éloigné
ça veut dire pendant une période donnée
6 mois 6 mois prés donc ils sont ils
peuvent pas recréer de compte ils ont
pour bien comprendre ah benah c'est ça
va être tout l'enjeu mais on va mettre
en place c'est ce que prévoi cette
directive une responsabilité des réseaux
sociaux c'est-à-dire la personne qui est
identifié qui aura fait la procédure
administrativo judiciaire je veux pas
préempter la solution queé vers laquelle
le législateur ira et bien sera exclu
pendant 6 mois c'est la responsabilité
du réseau de l'exclure pendant 6 mois
sil recrée par d'autres voies euh un
autre compte et que il reprend ses
activités de harcèlement à ce moment-là
la la sanction et la pénalité ira au
réseau donc on les responsabilise c'est
la directive européenne qui nous permet
de faire ça c'est la responsabilité
aussi des réseaux d'appliquer cette loi
si elle est beé si elle est adopté ils
aont des pénalités s'ils le font pas et
donc c'est une annonce importante
qu'onellement on renforce parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été faites ces
dernières années c'est un combat
absolument majeur parce qu'il est il est
terrible pour pour pour les les les
enfants les ados et les jeunes qu' le
vivent et donc on lâchera rien et on et
on note làdessus que Elisabeth born donc
la première ministre a déclaré Surel
qu'elle annoncerait un plan d'ici la fin
du mois il me semble sur l'harcellement
scolaire donc on aura l'occasion de
toute façon de notre côté d'en reparler
sur les dans les actus du jour ou dans
nos autres dans nos autres formats on va
passer rapidement à la question du PACT
enseignant si vous le voulez bien c'est
un sujet important que vous avez
présenté avec votre Ministre d'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal il y a maintenant
plusieurs mois mais qui a été précisé au
fil des au fil des semaines je me
permets de l'expliquer aussi pour que
tout le monde a le a le contexte et
après on va pouvoir si vous voulez bien
rentrer dans le détail sur le grand sur
le dispositif tel qu'il est le PACT
enseignant c'est donc il prévoit le fait
que que les enseignants merci beaucoup
que les enseignants puissent toucher un
complément de salaire en échange de
certaines missions qu'il viendrai qu'il
viendrait faire ça implique donc de
signer ce pacte de rentrer dans ce
processus là les missions dont on parle
qui sont possibles c'est la question de
remplacement de courte durée de leurs
collègues qui pourraient être absent
c'est la question du soutien scolaire
c'est la question de l'aide au devoir de
l'aide à l'orientation aussi il y a un
système de brick si on pe l'appeler
comme ça qui est mise en place et donc
les enseignants s'il souhaite et bien
participe à ce Pact qui a été donc
annoncé et en parallèle pour bien
compléter le tout on a là aussi beaucoup
parlé dans actum mais ça permet de faire
un petit rappel en parallèle à ça il y a
une hausse de salaire qui a été annoncée
cette hausse de salaire pour la rentrée
2023 elle est de 125 € entre 125 € et
259 € netes par mois par rapport à la
rentrée 2022 celle-ci elle est
inconditionnelle celle-ci elle est
inconditionnelle elle est pas elle ne
dépend pas de ce que vous allez faire ou
non dans le cadre du PACT enseignant euh
premier élément peut-être là-dessus sur
la question plus large de la
rémunération des enseignants on sait que
c'est un enjeu pour recruter des des
enseignants eu selon un rapport de
l'OCDE qui a effectué une comparaison
entre pays notamment pays européens en
parité de pouvoir d'achat donc ce qui
permet de d'avoir une comparaison qui
est plus juste on va dire entre les
différents pays le salaire statutaire
des enseignants en France reste et cette
augmentation ne le comble pas nettement
inférieur à celui de beaucoup de nos
voisins alors on parlait deallemagne
tout à l'heure comme modèle sur la
question du rythme le salaire en
Allemagne par exemple vous le savez très
sûrement c'est près de 92000 dollars en
parité de pouvoir d'achat autrement dit
un ça l'aire beaucoup plus important par
rapport à la France puisqueà la France
on est en moyenne à 43000 dollars avec
ce mode de calcul est-ce que cette
augmentation est réellement suffisante
pour faire en sorte d'attirer à nouveau
sur ce métier et valoriser on va dire ce
métier qui est évidemment important
alors les enquêtes de l' CDE elles
montrent très clairement qu'en fait on
avait un début de carrière on était on
payait beaucoup moins nos enseignants on
commenç à rattraper en milieu de
carrière en fin de carrière on est
compétitif par rapport aux autres dans
le CDE on a un niveau de retraite qui
est plutôt dans la moyenne haute de
l'OCDE parce qu'on a un système de
retraite dans la fonction publique qui
est qui est meilleur donc je dis ça
parce que dans le cycle du temps c'est
pas pareil et c'est pas aussi univoque
mais là c'est 15 ans de carrière 15 ans
d'ancienneté pour les chires que donc et
donc c'est pour ça que ce qu'on avait
besoin de corriger c'était le début et
le milieu de carrière ce qu'on a fait
puisque quand j'ai été élu la première
fois un un enseignant titulaire il était
recruté à 1600 1700 € net par mois aucun
aujourd'hui n'est recruté en dessous de
2100 € net par mois donc vous voyez que
le l'impact a été massif làdessus si je
me permets juste sur ce point du00 € sur
le site du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale profession mais il y a des
personnes qui sont ce qu'on appelle
stagiaires donc qui débutent sur
profession mais qui font leur travail à
temps plein ceux-ci sont en dessous
selon les chifffr je me Perm de donner
les chiffres du ministère d'éducation
nationale je prends je prends la peine
de vous dire pour les professeurs
titulaires en début de carrière mais
mais une personne stagiaire n'est pas en
début de carrière une personne stagiaire
est en début de carrière donc là vous
avez le traitement ind c'est sur site
donc c'est bien ce que je dis donc c'est
la ligne 2 qu'il faut prendre vous le
comptez à partir de la ligne 2 bah non
mais c'est la réalité parce que là c'est
pour ça que vous avez des stagiaires
donc qui sont en début de carrière mais
ils sont encore en formation donc ils
sont à
1900 c'est tout à fait vrai mais ils
sont payés 300 € de plus que des gens
qui étai à la ligne 2 c'est-à-dire qui
étaient des professeurs titulaires en
début de carrière 300 € de plus qu'au
début du quinena et enseignants juste
qu'on précise et même y compris pour le
publicère ici ça
enfinign ce sont des enseignants mais
ils sont pas reconnus comme professeur
titulaire et donc c'estes stagiares à
mi-temps je veux pas dire de bêtises
mais il devaaient être payé 1500 € par
mois il y a 4 ans donc ils sont passés
ils ont une augmentation de 400 € par MO
donc quand on dit tous les enseignants
titulaires comme ça a été dit par
certains ministres mais dire il faut pas
dire tous les enseignants parce que les
stagiares et les contractuels sont en
dessous si on dit tous les enseignants
titulaires on a raison parce que ça
commence à la ligne 2 mais les
enseignants général effectivement donc
les enseignants
stagous par Go là donc les enseignants
stagiaires comme vous le dites il y en a
qui sont en dessous et les contractuels
il y en a qui sont en dessous c'est
important aussi à dire si vous devez
être exhaustif parce que mais les
professeurs titulaires dès la première
année ils sont bien au-udessus de 20000
contractuel effectivement son entre 1700
et 2000 € BR selon leur niveau de
diplôme mais c'est tout le monde a été
revalorisé de manière inédite on avait
pas fait un tel investissement depuis 90
bon donc pour que vous ça c'est toujours
les chiffres je sais pas ce que si ça
parle vraiment au gens non mais les
chiffres macro mais ça fait 3,7 milliard
d'euros l'année dernière et cette année
à chaque fois 3,7 + 3,7 de revalo bon
dans un contexte d'inflation au passage
mais qui n'a pas oui alors c'est tout à
fait vrai quand vous dites 125 à 250 €
net ça prend l'indice et la partie
inflation néanmoins il y a une
augmentation en vrai qui correspond aux
engagements qui été pris donc ça c'est
la partie inconditionnelle c'est-à-dire
là là la grille que vous aviez qui était
très bien fichue on peut la remettre si
vous voulez on peut la remettre c'est
quelqu'un qui a pas signé le PACT c'est
quelqu'un qui fait son service et il
fait pas de de mission en plus et qui
travaille déjà mais qui travaille qui
est de devant les élèves avec ses heures
ça dépend après de de de diplôes et
cetera mais qui fait ses heures bon
après donc ça c'est un point clé mais
donc on a revalorisé et on a on est en
train de rattraper les autres européens
pour le début et milieu de carrière bon
et moi c'est une bataille clé parce
qu'il faut rerendre ce métier qui est
absolument fondamental dont on a besoin
pour no nos enfants nos adolescents
attractif et de deè chose le PACT vous
l'avez dit moi j'y crois beaucoup on a
besoin d'abord de reconnaître des tâches
qui sont faites par les enseignants
aujourd'hui pour lesqueles ils ne sont
pas payés l'aide au devoir le
remplacement des collègues qui sont pas
là et cetera vous avez énormément de
profs enfin d'enseignants pardon qui
font ça qui aujourd'hui sont pas mieux
payés que le copain qui décide de faire
son service juste et le pack c'est la
reconnaissance d'un engagement et
ensuite on en a besoin pour faire
fonctionner au plus près du terrain le
système j'insiste sur un point que vous
avez évoqué ce sont les remplacements
on a 15 millions 15 millions d'heures
d'enseignement qui sont perdus chaque
année parce que sur des des des absences
très courtes il y a pas de remplacement
trouvé alors une partie c'est la faute
de notre système c'est-à-dire qu'on met
des formations aux enseignants dans du
temps scolaire donc ça on on va faire
max des besoins de remplacement on les
enlever mais après c'est parce que alors
il y a des écoles qui le font déjà moi
j'ai été par dans l'héro il y a quelques
mois dans un un collège formidable ils
le font en payant sur des heures sup les
profs et ils ont en quelque sorte vous
avez vos heures d'enseignement c'est les
heures vertes euh vous avez des heures
oranges c'est j'enseigne pas mais je
suis disponible pour remplacer les
collègues les heures rouges c'est là je
suis pas du tout disponible je corriger
les copies ou je ne sais quoi voilà et
donc là on sait chaque jour le matin on
arrive le d'Ang pas et ben on dit tu vas
l'école la classe va va être prise par
le prof de math et il se débrou mais
très précisément et a-elà du fait comme
vous le dites que le cours d'anglais
peut-être remplacé par le cours de maths
ce qui amène selon les Syndicates
professeur à certains problèmes parce
que certains disent que bah du coup on
ne rattrape pas forcément un retard qu'
aait pris un mat ou autre par
c'est du bon sens élémentaire c'est que
le jour où le prof de math si je suis
enseignant et que j'ai que mon prof
d'anglais qui est absent toute l'année
et que je suis remplacé par du mat alors
ça pour le coup on le règle différemment
je ça c'est une confusion qui est
malhonnête si on dit ça ah ben ça c'est
une question qui revient beaucoup donc
je me per permet de la régler les
remplacement longs on ne les gère pas
par des remplacements des cè quand j'ai
dis tout le temps j'entends j'entends
pas tout le tempsné j'ends remplacement
d'abord faut mesurer une chose durant
mon premier quinquena je me suis battu
pour qu'on améliore les remplacements
partout dans l'école les seules absences
de qu'on mesuré c'est les absences de
plus de 15 jours quand vous avez une
absence de plus de 15 jours le rectorat
envoie quelqu'un et vous avez dans tous
les rectorats des professeurs qui sont
justement parfois des stagiaires ou des
professeurs qui sont en appoint et qui
sont des des collègues qui sont
déployés et qui sont aussi pour certains
des enseignants très expérimentés qui
sont déployés dans les écoles ou les
collèges ou les lycées ENF c'estàd c'est
tou plus les collèges et les lycées et
qui viennent faire des remplacements
donc si vous avez pendant 4 mois votre
prof de mat qui est absent là le
rectorat doit dépêcher un remplaçant il
y aura un enseignant en mathématique qui
viendra remplacer sur le plus long terme
on est d'accord r là on parle on parle
on parle des absences qui peuvent
parfois êre répété ouv mais qui sont des
absences très courtes et donc là si le
collègue d'anglais prend l'heure bah
quand le prof de mat revient il reprend
une heure d'anglais très et très
rapidement sur la question du pactign
sur la question du PACT enseignant très
rapidement donc on le redit plus en plus
du du du travail de base plus d'heur
pour certaines missions mais qui sont du
coup rémunéré ce qui vient compléter le
salaire l'enjeu ici c'est la question de
la charge de travail des enseignants et
des professeurs selon la Direction de
l'évaluation de la prospective et de la
performance qui date de 2022 les
enseignants français au primaire et au
collège lycée sont parmi ceux qui
travaillent le plus en Europe déjà
aujourd'hui sans parler donc des mission
supplémenta graphique c'est compte étant
tenu des missions alors bah non là c'est
des chiffres de 2020 2021 non mais parce
que ce que je veux dire c'est que les
enquête si c'est l'enquête de la DEP euh
c'est ça je pense oui c'est ça ou c'est
ça exactement et l'enquête de cette
direction que vous avez cité
intègre prend en compte les ce que font
mais c'est c'est en fait les heures d
par le système et les heures que font
beaucoup de collègues mais en fait c'est
inégalement réparti elles ne sont pas
aujourd'hui valorisé dans la
rémunération très rapidement là-dessus
quand on parle on est d'accord sur le
pacte enseignant dans les différentes
briques je mettrai des liens en
description pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien mais on est on a des
briques qui sont sur l'aide à
l'orientation qui sont sur l'A de voir
sur des dispositifs qui sont mis en
place à partir de la rentrée pour
essayer de combler les inégalités
l'enjeu qui est soulevé par un certain
nombre de de d'enseignants et de
professeurs c'est que et bien non
seulement d'un point de vue de la
rémunération et bien les enseignants
doivent travailler encore plus pour bien
gagner plus et d'un point de vue de la
charge de travail totale sur ces
nouvelles missions et bien elle soit en
fait impossible à aller aller chercher
ou à aller faire puisque et bien ils
sont déjà parmi les enseignants qui
travaillent le plus alors de deux choses
la
première c'est la meilleure défense de
la nécessité de revoir le temps scolaire
dans l'année ce qu'on évoqueé tout à
l'heure parce que quand vous voyez ça
vous voyez bien qu'on peut pas être en
même temps ceux qui avont le moins de
semaines de temps scolaire dans l'année
ce qui est le cas l'fance on est parmi
les plus bas ça c'est une étude de
l'OCDE la deuxième chose c'est que cette
cette heure moyenne annuelle qui est
prise en compte intègre beaucoup
d'émissions enfin même les missions qui
sont dans le pacte mon point c'est de
dire que devoir fait c'est un c'est un
système qui existe aujourd'hui le
remplacement il existe en théorie il est
dans le code simplement aujourd'hui le
système il repose sur une partie des
enseignants et ceux qui donnent en plus
que leur ce qu'ils doivent de manière
légale ne sont pas reconnus comme il
faut et donc c'est pour ça que j'insiste
sur ce point le pacte ne vient pas
inventer des nouvelles missions toutes
ces missions existent pour certaines je
par qui sign le PACT ne travailleront
pas plus il en fait mon point c'est de
dire les enseignants qui signent le
pacte je veux pas prter parce qu'ils
sont en train de le faire mais ce sont
déjà des gens qui travaillent plus que
ce qu'on croit qu'il travaillent mais
simplement ces heures là ne sont pas
reconnu et c'est ce que le système doit
dans votre 720hur fait par laadep il y a
les heures de remplacement donc ce que
vous dit la réalité c'est qu'elles sont
pas toujours effectives et donc nous on
les rend effectives donc dans dans ces
720h je veux qu'on a les heur on va
passer un are sujet mais juste pouréser
ce que vous dit c'est que ces heuresl
sont intégré dans le PACT enseignant
mais bien sûr parce que aujourd'hui
d'abord un le remplacement il doit être
légalement fait comment vous expliquez
que vis-à-vis des parents et des élèves
on a un système qui est 15 millions
d'heures non remplacé de le système de
voirfit il existe les systèmes
d'accompagnement ils existent mais il
reposent sur des enseignants qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas reconnus par le
système et bien valorisé le PACT il va
permettre donc vous l'avez dit
l'augmentation pour un prof un
enseignant qui ne prend pas le PACT
c'est 125 à 250 € nets de plus par mois
de rentré à rentrée ce chiffre il va
être porté à 500 € voire 700 € dans le
lycée professionnel de plus par mois
c'est très clair sur ce suj et on verra
du coup l'application dans qu on est
dansation qui sont autour de 2000 je
peux vous dire que ça change la vie si
si si vous voulez bien on va passer à un
autre sujet pour une raison très simple
ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on qu'on parle
et je je me doute qu'il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants qui attendent qu'on parle
d'étudiants d'ailleurs et de non
étudiant dro de dire à la cavalcade tout
ce qu'on va faire à l'école en rentrée
je le fais hyper vite pour que vous
qu'on a le temps d'aller dévoquer la
suite moi ça me temps mais à cette
rentrée on va commencer à accueillir
dans les quartiers en difficulté dès 2
ans à la maternelle hyper important on
continue de dédoubler les grandes
sections de maternelle vous savez qu'un
des truc dont je suis le plus fier c'est
le dédoublement dans les zones qu'on
appelle REP et REP plus du cpce1 on va
entre cette rentrée et la suivante
généraliser pour la grande section de
maternelle hyper important on met en
place plus de de d'enseignements de
fondamentaux aux primaires la demiure de
sport partout au primaire et
l'évaluation CP CE1 CM1 mais aussi au
collège 6e 4e c'est sur la base de ces
évaluations qu'on va pouvoir beaucoup
mieux identifier les élèves qui sont
près décrocheurs ou décrocheurs et les
difficultés et les accom accag on va
permettre pour tous ceux qui ont des
difficultés je l'espère d'avoir des
prérentrées et de mieux les accompagner
plus des heures de soutien on met en
place l'éducation artistique et
culturelle au primaire à la 6e on va
permettre de mettre en place une heure
de soutien en math ou en français pour
ceux qui en ont besoin système c'est
hyper important on développera les
échélégués ce qui a un formidable succès
ces dernières années pour que l'écologie
soit pleinement intégré dans la
formation et que nos collégiens et nos
lycéens soient des acteurs de l'écologie
et je veux en particulier sur notre
objectif forêt je vous l'annonce là
c'est un point hyper important je veux
que on est dès la 6e de cette année
qu'on commence à avoir des élèves qui
plantent des arbres et qu'on ait cette
génération où chaque collégien aura
planté son arbre on n arrivera pas je
pense à le faire pour l'intégralité des
6è mais si on a chaque génération qui PL
de son Arre ils vont nous aider à aller
à notre milliard de de reboisement c'est
hyper important pour la sainte caerine
ensuite je continue donc peê pas ça qui
rersera la cour des émissions de G mais
pas plus que ce que vous m'avez dit tout
à l'heure sur prendre moins
d'avion non c'est tous ces gestes ce que
je vous ai dit sur l'avion plus j'évite
un vol inutile plus en effet je reboise
pardon comme vous l'z dit y il y a des
choses qui ont plus d'impact que d'
c'est pas juste de dire que forcément ce
qui dans le débat public a plus d'impact
que ce que le président de la République
c'est pas ce que je dis mais
là j'ai ma part du Colibri j'ai le droit
et elle a autant de gueule que celle que
celle des copains je suis c'est
scientifiqu mais en l'occurrence mais
non mais moi aussi c'est les
scientifiques il faut reboiser et donc
ensuite le collège on continue on va
mettre en place dès la 5e la journée à
venir c'est-à-dire que il y aura une
demi-journée tous les 15 jours où on
présente les métiers aux jeunes ensuite
on mettra en place on on reprend une
heure de math quel que
soit dans le dans dans le lycée et on
fait la réforme du bac qui fait que les
spécialités ne seront pas en mars elles
sont en juin mais en juin ça je pense
que les les licen sont au courant on
fait la réf de parcours su qu'on va
finaliser dans quelques semaines on aura
pas le temps d'en parler ça aujourd'hui
mais une vraie révolution sur le lycée
pro qui est une cause nationale un tiers
des lycéens et on fait un changement
profond grâce au prof
grâce aux directrices enfin au chefs
d'établissement et grâce aux élèves on
passe à la question de des étudiants il
y a forcément énormément de sujets c'est
normal c'est une interview de de rentrée
merci au passage à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent si vous suivez cette
interview en en direct on passe la
question des étudiants on va aller plus
largement sur la question de de la
jeunesse mais sur la question des
étudiants pour permettre à chacun
évidemment d'avoir des études dans des
bonnes conditions et d'accueillir tous
les étudiants qu'il souhaitent il y a
évidemment une question de moyen une
question de
budget quand on se rend sur le site du
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur on
apprend c'est le ministère qui le qui
l'indique que le budget par étudiant est
en baisse ces dernières années alors ça
ne remonte pas à qu'ot quinquena c'était
même avant ça depuis 2014 on est en
moyenne sur une baisse de 1,4 % du
budget par étudiant même la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur syv Tao a
expliqué au président d'université qu'il
n'y aurait pas de miracle en cette
rentrée c'est ce qu'elle a expliqué au
président d'université qui était inquiet
de voir d'un côté CER une ambition sur
l'enseignement supérieur mais de l'autre
côté un besoin un enjeu une demande de
réduction des coûts à l'université dans
le contexte actuel la crainte qui est
très présente ma question est un peu
longue mais j'arrive au bout est-ce que
le risque là c'est pas une sélection à
l'université qui ne dit pas son nom mais
qui finit par s'appliquer avec des
universités qui n'ont plus les moyens
d'accueillir des nouveaux élèves non je
crois pas du tout mais je vais vous
expliquer comment on y arrive d'abord je
veux redire dans quel pays nous
vivons l'université est gratuite en
France regardez à travers le monde là
aussi euh qui est
comparable durant mon premier quinena
nous avons pris en charge la sécurité
sociale
étudiante c'est plusieurs centaines
d'euros par an pour un étudiant parfois
ça dépassé le millier et donc nous
sommes dans un pays et un/ers de nos
étudiants sont boursiers alors après il
y a une échelle de selon le les les les
revenus des parents mais un/ers sont
boursiers donc nous avons l'un des
systèmes qui socialise le plus le coût
des études supérieurs ça c'est une
réalité et quand on parle de nos études
supérieures de nos étudiants je pense
qu'il faut jamais perdre ça de vue parce
que c'est une force de la France c'est
une chance mais on a aussi un modèle qui
est extraordinairement généreux une fois
qu'on a dit ça un jeune sur qu vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté malgré cette
situation c'est tout à fait vrai mais ça
mon
pourquoi parce que on doit avoir aussi
un système plus clair on a plus de 80 %
d'une génération qui arrive au bac quel
est le but des études supérieures de
pouvoir avoir un métier un avenir qu'on
choisit or aujourd'hui quand je regarde
les chiffres 50 % des jeunes qui
s'inscrivent en licence ne vont pas se
présenter à l'examen ou l'avoir donc on
a un énorme problème d'orientation et on
a une forme de gachi collectif ou de
moyens mis à l'université non c'est pas
des moyens pardon c'est pas des moyens
avec les moyens qu'on met on doit faire
beaucoup mieux d'abord on doit avoir de
la transparence pour les élèves et les
familles sur ce qu'il y a au bout d'une
formation et pour nous pour la
collectivité et pour les universités les
universités sont autonomes mais quand
vous avez des formations qui depuis des
années ne diplôme quasiment pas vous
pensez à laquelle ou auquel non j'ai pas
de je stigmatise personne je veux pour
la transparence moi je veux qu'on mette
en place on a commencé la transparence
c'est exactement comme on fait
d'ailleurs pour le lycée pro vous avez
deux critères est-ce que les élèves ont
un diplôme h enfin les étudiants ont un
diplôme etce qu'après le diplôme ils ont
des emplois quand vous avez des
formations vous avez une minorité de
jeunes qui vont à l'examen qui ont après
un diplôme et quasiment aucun qui ont un
emploi
pardonahut un enjeu d'orientation mais
il y a un enjeu il y a un attendez c'est
hyper important ce que je dis donc ça
c'est la révolution que j'ai demandé
pour la rentrée prochaine et les
universités avec budget elles doivent
faire beaucoup mieux c'estàd elles
doivent avoir le courage de dire on
laisse pas ouvert des formations parce
qu'on a des profs sur ces formations
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait parfois et on
doit dire en face est-ce que cette
formation d'abord elle me permet de
former des jeunes et elle me permet
d'avoir un emploi à l'inverse j'ai des
formations aujourd'hui qui se passent
dans de Mau conditions parce que
beaucoup trop de jeunes s'inscrivent or
on sait qu'ell permettent d'avoir des
diplômes et des emplois dans la question
de complètement réalouer les choses donc
les moyens honnêtement on va la ministre
a eu raison de dire on n'est pas un pays
qui sousinvestit sur son enseignement
supérieur on est parmi les P mais il y a
un coup par étudiant qui en baisse
dernies anné mais rapidement c'est la
question de la précarité question hyper
important on se
dit le système ne pourra pas être plus
efficace s'il n'y a pas d'abord un
système qui fait davantage contribuer
ceux qui ont plus de moyen on est le
seul donc plusieurs universités sont
rentrées là-dedans y compris vis-à-vis
des étudiants étrangers aujourd'hui vous
êtes fils de milliardaaires américains
vous êtes fils de milliardaires
africains vous êtes fils de
milliardaires asiatiqu vous arrivez dans
une université française tout vous est
payé il y a pas un pays au monde qui
fait ça donc on doit aussi réfléchir à
comment on met à contribution les gens
qui ont le plus de moyens si on veut
bien faire ensuite on doit avoir le
courage de revoir nos formations et de
se dire est-ce qu'elles sont diplômantes
et est-ce qu'on sont qualifiantes et il
faut ensuite que les universités
développent aussi des formations plus
courtes et qui sont plus qualifiantes et
de le faire au plus près du terrain ce
qui fait la transition avec votre
question sur la précarité étudiante
parce que quelle est une des sources de
la précarité c'est le coût de la vie et
justement sur le vie et donc le sujet
aussi c'est qu' on doit en lien avec les
universités les écoles d'ingénieurs les
écoles de commerce et C développer
beaucoup plus de formations courtes
c'est-à-dire qu' peuvent être entre 1 et
3 ans diplôante et qualifiante dans des
villes périphériques où le coût de la
vie est beaucoup plus important dans des
villes moyennes mais sur le coût de la
vie alors il y a des choses qui sont
indépendante quasiment du lieu où vous
vivez un exemple important c'est la
question de la hausse des prix de
l'inflation alors c'est plus cher à
Paris d'aller au supermarché que d'aller
dans une ville moins moins peuplée mais
tout de même globalement les prix
augmentent partout on on on le sait un
élément évidment de important donc c'est
un une question très rapidement avant de
passer à autre chose c'est la question
de de la Bourse c'est évidemment un
dispositif majeur pour aider les
étudiants aujourd'hui elle a augmenté de
37 € en cette année pour tous les
échelons donc pour les personnes après
après discussion concertation qui a fait
la ministre qui qui a été pris qui a été
pris par par votre par le gouvernement
et donc sur ce sujet précisément pour
les plus modestes le dernier échelon ça
correspond à une augmentation à hauteur
de l'inflation donc c'est-à-dire aux
alentours de 5,8 % merci
beaucoup l'enjeu et qui est soulevé
notamment par les syndicat étudiant
c'est que certes l'inflation est à 5 %
mais l'augmentation des prix des
éléments qui sont achetés par des
étudiants notamment l'alimentation à n'a
pas augmenté de 5 % mais a augmenté de
15 % autrement dit le retour d'un
certain nombre de d'étudiants c'est que
certes il y a une augmentation mais qui
ne fait pas face à l'augmentation des
prix pour un pour un étudiant d'abord
vous avez c'est un un sujet qui est très
important je redis on est dans un pays
où on on accompagne beaucoup et moi je
m'en félicite je pense c'est une force
nos étudiants on va de toute façon
évaluer et continuer de suivre et donc
on va regarder là dans les prochaines
semaines comme vous l'avez vu on essaie
plutôt de se battre pour baisser les
prix alimentaires donc on pourrait
augmenter le les bourses de toute façon
on laa pas des jeunes en particulier moi
je suis pas totalement pour qu'on
l'augmente pour toutes les catégories
c'est ce qu'on a fait une première fois
mais pour les catégories les plus
modestes ou les jeunes qui son
difficulté exactement 7 qu'on ait un
geste supplémentaire si il y a une
confirmation dans les prochaines
semaines sur la question parce que la
rentrée est pas encore faite s'il a s'il
y a une confirmation dans les prochaines
semaines sur les prix de l'alimentation
je pense qu'il faudra le regarder après
la bataille qu'on mène pour vous parler
franchement c'est plutôt de faire
baisser les prix parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on regarde nos agriculteurs ils font
pas des surprofit il faut les protéger
parce qu'ils vivent déjà en grande
difficulté mais on a quelques groupes de
l'agroalimentaire qui font des surprofit
qui ont passé des hausses de prix
massives et c'est plutôt d'ailleurs les
industriels qui sont sur les biens que
achètent beaucoup les étudiants les gens
les plus modestes et cetera donc là on
est dans un rapport de force où on est
en train là de les contraindre et de les
menacer on prendra des décisions pour
que les prix baissent donc je
préférerais de manière générale qu'on
arrive à faire baisser les prix et qu'on
ait pas besoin d'augmenter les bourses
pour les étudiants l'échelon 7 et en
tout cas les plus modestes sinon on le
fera donc s'il y a une hausse des prix
qui se poursuit il y aura une
augmentation des bourses à priori pour
les échelons les plus importants dans
les autres éléments de de qui concerne
la question de la précarité des jeunes
encore une fois c'est un sujet très
vaste ça peut être frustrant de de pas
pouvoir aborder tous les sujets et
toutes les problématiques de notre de
notre génération mais il y a notamment
la question des soins de santé en 2023
près de 4 millions de Françaises sont
victimes de précarité menstruelle donc
lorsqu'une femme ne peut pas se fournir
en protection hygiénique par manque tout
simplement de moyens ce chiffre là c'est
un chiffre qui est important c'est
quasiment deux fois plus qu'en 2021 donc
on voit que c'est un problème qui prend
de
l'ampleur en mars il me semble que votre
gouvernement avait annoncé le rembor le
remboursement pardon des protections
périodiques réutilisables pour les moins
de 25 ans ouis ma question làdus est
très simple est-ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité et si c'est toujours
d'actualité quelle forme ça va prendre
pour pour ces étudiantes ou jeun j'ai
juste un micro point parce que j'avais
oublié pour ça je recherchais les
chiffres dans mon dossier faut pas
oublier les APL aussi qui ont été
revalorisés de 3,5 % ce qui il y av une
baisse en début de de quinen 5 € qui
avait été prise en truc on a fait plus
que les rattraper et là la r
valorisation non que je bien le prendre
comme paradra mais quand même euh la la
la baisse vaut nettement nettement moins
que la suppression de la sécurité
sociale étudiante que j'aiévoqué mais là
je rappelais ça va en plus du reste oui
l'engagement l'engagement sera tenu et
sur les protections hygiéniques
réutilisables pour les moins de 25 ans
25 ans compris elles seront elles seront
remboursées en 2024 en pharmacie et en
2025 sur une plateforme en ligne dédiée
qui permettra d'acheter ces ces
protections très clair exement et
l'engagement qui a été pris par ailleurs
puisque vous parlez de santé de pr
prévention donc ça c'est un engagement
très important sur le plan social
puisque vous parlez de d'engagement de
prévention je rappelle aussi
l'engagement que j'ai pris sur les
préservatifs avec la gratuité des
préservatif jusqu'à 25 ans qui est hyper
important et sur lequel il faut
continuer d'expliquer d'y aller parce
que c'est un élément de prévention hyper
important donc n'oubliez pas que c'est
que c'est gratuit autre sujet que je
vous propose d'aborder on approche de la
de la fin mais rapidement on a parlé
alors de sujets généraux en début de en
début d'entretien de la question de
l'environnement de la question de la
santé mentale on a parlé de la question
de l'éducation plein d'autres sujets
évidemment qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait
évoquer mais on a essayé de de se
pencher sur certains de ces de ces
éléments là on a parlé des étudiants il
faut évidemment avoir en tête que tout
le monde n'est pas étudiant ou
évidemment à l'école et c'est justement
un chiffre qui est assez important
aujourd'hui on estime selon les chiffres
d'Eurostat que c'est un jeune sur 8 qui
est ni étudiant ni en formation ni en
emploi un jeune sur 8 c'est assez
important c'est 12,8 des jeunes de 15 à
29 ans et c'est un nombre qui ne baisse
pas ces dernières années globalement
depuis plusieurs années maintenant en
train de le baisser alors selon avec les
derniers chiffres de 2021 c'est stable
depuis à mimage que 2021 et on verra sur
les chiffres suivants bah on est en
train de le baisser il a le chiffre des
ce qu'on appelle les nits ouais qui sont
ni en emploi ni en formation il a
commencé à baisser même avant 21 je sais
pas là pour le coup quelles étaient vos
sources mais alors là c'est Eurostat
Eurostat surc apprentissage on mettra
dans tous les cas él on passera les les
les chiffres là-dessus ce qui est un des
points clés donc qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire là-dessus un d'abord le la
conséquence de
de en effet ce sacrifice en quelque
sorte qui ait la société on avait trop
de jeunes qui chaque année n'ét N en
emploi ni en formation c'est le
décrochage donc là c'est la bataille
qu'on mène sur les savoirs fondamentaux
pour l'évaluation pour lutter contre le
décrochage avant et au collège et c'est
tout le boulot qu'on fait sur le lycée
pro parce que beaucoup de cénistes
venaient du lycée professionnel où on va
vers on met en place un plan zéro
décrocheurst arrêté leurs études au licé
au cours de leur ex et souvent ils les
arrêent pourquoi parce qu'il y a un
dégoût de l'école pourquoi parce qu'on a
pas bien acquis les savoirs fondamentaux
et qu'on a on est envoyé en 6e alors
qu'on sait pas bien lire écrire et
compter et qu'on n' pas acquis les
savoirs fondamentaux donc on est noyé et
puis on conçoit un dégoût complet de
l'école bon donc ça c'est tout ce que
j'ai dit avant sur l'école qui va
permettre de le réduire et la réforme du
lycée pro de c'est
ensuite d'aller vers ce que j'ai
commencé à dire sur l'université
pourquoi on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont S formation ou qui sont sans emploi
parce qu'on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
vont dès après bac vers un système
universitaire qui n'est pas adapté pour
eux quand je vous dis et les chiffres
sont nos chiffres officiels qu'on a 50 %
des jeunes qui vont se présenter à
l'examen en L1 où sont les 50 % autres
alors certains se réorientent
heureusement certains vont finir par y
aller l'année d'après et cetera mais
vous en perdez plein qui en fait ont des
problèmes d'orientation donc on doit
améliorer l'orientationentation dès la
5e vous l'avez évoqué ou mais même avec
parcours c'est boulot et avoir un
système qui est beaucoup plus
transparent qui accompagne beaucoup
mieux humainement ça c'est la réforme de
parcours sup et qui est plus transparent
pour arrêter avec les formations qui ne
mènent nulle part trois c'est
l'apprentissage et ça c'est la petite
révolution qu'on a mis en place pour ça
qu'on a quand même commencé à faire
baisser les chiffres il y a 5 ans on
avait entre 230 et 250000 apprentis par
an au moment où je vous parle on est
autour de 900000 apprentis et on
touchera le million d'apprentis par an
et de manière durable ça c'est une
révolution parce que on a dedans des
diplômés dans million dans ces 900000
aujourd'hui il y en a qui étaient dans
le système éducatif avant mais il y en a
d'autres qui sinon étaient complètement
laissés pour compte et il s'insèent
beaucoup mieux et donc c'est ce qui
permet d'améliorer progressivement le
taux d'activité et le taux d'emploi des
moins de 25 ans et puis après on a mis
en place des dispositifs d'aide comme la
garantie et donc ça c'est tout le
mécanisme qu'on a mis en place
d'ailleurs pendant le covid un jeune une
solution merci le contrat d'engagement
jeune et autrre mais la plateforme à
jeune une solution c'est celle qui vous
permet quand vous êtes dans cette
situation et bien de soumettre votre cas
et vous avez une réponse dédiée qui peut
être une formation courte qui peut être
un contrat d'engagement jeune qui peut
être un emploi et cetera mais là-dessus
plus largement d'ailleurs c'est une
question aussi qui revient beaucoup il y
a eu alors il y a des débats depuis
longtemps sur ce sujet-là les chercheurs
aussi qui se pensent sur le sujet c'est
la question de la situation des jeunes
en France en terme d'accès y compris sur
les aides qui peuvent être proposé vous
serez d'accord avec moi là-dessus à 18
ans on peut voter on peut sans ager en
politique on peut on commence souvent à
à travailler pour justement financer ces
études à côté bref on est présent dans
la vie active on est responsable
pénalement on est présent dans la vie
active une demande qui est présente
depuis longtemps c'est de la part une
demande de la part des des syndicat
c'est la question des aides qui sont
proposées notamment pour des jeunes qui
seraient sortis du circuit qui seraient
en difficulté et qui ne se retrouvent
pas systématiquement avec les mêmes
aides que les adultes qui auraient plus
de 25 ans par exemple et donc l'un des
éléments une des questions qui fait
beaucoup débat c'est la question du RSA
la question d'élargir avec le même
fonctionnement et le même principe le
RSA pour les plus de 25 ans que pour les
moins de 25 ans ce sujet-là revient
souvent sur la table à chaque élection à
présidentielle on l'a vu aujourd'hui
quelle est votre position là-dessus et
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous ne souhaitez
pas qu'un jeune qui présente des
difficultés pour toutes les raisons
qu'on a pu voir aujourd'hui quel qu'elle
soit ne puisse pas bénéficier de cette
aide làà ou pas de la même façon d'abord
euh on est en train de faire une réforme
du RSA dans le cadre de France travail
pour davantage le nouveau nom de Pô
emploi je pr et le nouveau nom de Pôle
Emploi qui qu'on rapproche avec
lesémions local et tous les acteurs pour
que ça se simplifie c'est que on a on
doit mieux accompagner celles et ceux
qui sont loin de l'emploi qui sont RSA
mieux les former les accompagner
répondre aussi aux difficultés qu'ils
ont qui sont pas que de qualification
mais qui peuvent être des problèmes de
logement de transport de garde d'enfants
et aussi parfois recréer les incitations
qui font que l'emploi est plus
intéressant que d'être aidé aujourd'hui
pourquoi on a ce système qui commence
tous les système est depuis toujours
dans notre droit à 25 ans parce que
jusqu'à 25 ans on prévoit une solidarité
familiale et donc ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'on est dans un système où et ça
correspond aussi à la manière dont les
bourses sont pensées et cetera on
regarde la contribution la capacité
contributive de la famille donc il y a
une dépendance finalement de la
famillee oui mais on responsabilise les
familles et objectivement dans un pays
comme le nôtre où on est en train on a
déjà socialisé beaucoup de choses
c'est-à-dire c'est la communauté
nationale qui paye pour beaucoup je veux
dire elle paye votre école votre collège
votre lycée votre université elle paye
une bonne partie de votre santé elle
paye une bonne partie de des des sujets
du grand âge et on on est en train de
continuer à réformer bon est-ce que le
la priorité c'est de continuer à étendre
le domaine qui est à la fin payé par
quelqu'un qui est le
contribuable moi je pense que notre
système il est plus adapté aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah on a un système
qui dépend de votre cas et donc quand
vous êtes un jeune qui est dans le cas
que vous évoquez si vous pouvez aller
vers l'apprentissage on vous envoie
aujourd'hui vers l'apprentissage et vous
êtes payé par l'emplo urs avec une aide
de l'ét si vous êtes sorti du circuit et
que dansmédi d'abord il y a aucune
fatalité à 18 ans pardon mais euh il
faut que le système vous responsabilise
et donc il y a aucune fatalité pour dire
un on vous amène je l'espère vers
l'emploi plein et entier ou vers les
études pleines et entières ça c'est le
système le prévoit et vous accompagne et
les
paye TR c'est l'apprentissage qui est
une formeidable voit de passage pour
aller vers la professionnalisation où on
a simplifié où on aide vous êtes payé
par l'employeur avec une aide importante
de l'État 4 si vous décrochez beaucoup
plus qui est le cas que vous avez en
tête là on a mis en place des systèmes
ad hoc et le contrat d'engagement jeune
je le crois préférable au RSA pourquoi
parce que il permet de vous accompagner
de vous former ça peut se compléter non
mais en fait il est plus exigeant en
terme d'heur et d'accompagnement et
honnêtement qu'est-ce qu'on est en train
de faire sur le RSA sur le RSA on est en
train de renforcer les exigences et les
mécanismes de responsabilité parce qu'on
avait vu que le système tel qu'il avait
été pensé en 1988 il avait complètement
perdu la voix qui était la partie
insertion qui était au fond c'est un
contrat on vous donne un revenu de
solidarité mais vous devez vous former
vous devez rester dans la société vous
devez tout faire pour revenir à un
moment vers l'emploi on avait
complètement laissé tomber par manque
d'investissement on mettait pas assez de
travailleurs sociaux pas assez d'effort
et puis par
désengagement honnêtement c'est c'est
quand même souvent des situations
dramatiques donc on est en train
attendez pour les plus de 25 ans on est
en train d'essayer de faire cette
révolution c'estàdire de de changer
complètement le RSA avec France travail
pour aller responsabiliser réinvestir
remettre de l'aide qui pas la
qualification mais souvent est-ce que
c'est une question de responsabilité ou
est-ce que c'est une question de
détresse pour beaucoup de jeun on par
sémental au début les questions
économiques sont est en train de faire
avec de ramener le RSA à quelque chose à
quelque chose qui ressemble au contrat
d'engagement jeune en terme d'exigence
on a
bâti donc c'est le modèle des jeunes qui
est appliqué à
l'échelle je trouve qu'il est mieux
parce que il est beaucoup plus il est
plus entre guillemets contraignant et
responsabilisant et donc il y avait la
garantie qui existait qui était un
mécanisme assez lourd la garantie
c'était de l'argent qu' versait au 18 25
ans qui était dans ces situations de
très grand décrochage mais avec un
engagement assez fort vous estimez quand
on est au RSA on n' pas la volonté
spontanément naturellement de vouloir un
travail reprendre ses études s' sortir
non je dis il y a une palette faut
jamais faire de raccourci dans les dans
dans nos compatriotes qui sont RSA on a
des gens qui sont chômeurs de longue
durée qui sont tombés RSA et qui si on
leur donne un coup de pouce c'est la
formation qui va bien retrouve un emploi
on est en train d'en sortir on baisse he
le RSA dans plein de départements de
vous avez des gens qui sont sortis
depuis longtemps il faut les requalifier
et ils ont besoin parfois d'une
formation de 6 12 24 mois faut la payer
et donc c'est ce qu'on fait avec France
travail TR on a certains nos
compatriotes qui sont qui ont besoin de
formation mais qui se sont désocialisés
parce qu'ils ont plus et qui ont du mal
à se lever ont du mal à se remettre dans
des conditions de vie faut les
accompagner et ça c'est pas que des
formations ils ont besoin qu'on les les
aide qu'on leur tende la main et ça ce
sont des travailleuses et des
travailleurs sociaux c'est
l'investissement qu'on fait il y a des
associations qui font un formidable
travail à TD carmond beaucoup d'autres
de lutte contre la pauvreté de lutte
contre la pauvreté mais les missions
locales donc ça c'est ce qu'on intègre
dedans et puis 4atre on a des gens qui
sont bloqués qui sont sans solution je
vais vous prendre un exemple très
concret une maman solo qui est au RSA si
vous lui proposez un emploi mais qu'elle
a pas de solution de garde elle ne peut
pas prendre cet emploi et donc c'est ce
que je vous disais c'est tout le non
monétaire et le non formation mais qui
sont trouvé des solutions de garde
d'enfant de déplacement de logement donc
c'est C ensemble et puis après les
derniers derniers cas vous avez des gens
ur ça qui ne veulent pas bosser ça
existe aussi vous considérez qu'ils sont
sont si nombreux que ça je je suis
incapable et je crois que personne n'est
capable de les chiffrer mais vous avez
toute cette réalité et dans le débat
politique on attendrait sans caricaturer
donc les uns disent il y en a zéro les
autres disent S sont tous comme ça moi
je vous dis c'est la réalité à peu près
je crois avoir couvert toutes les
situations de des personnes au RSA la
question étant de savoir le la
répartition de chacun non la question
c'est et c'est ce qu'on veut faire avec
France travail et c'est ce que je veux
faire pour les 18 25 ans qui sont dans
cette situation là c'est responsabiliser
aider et donc vous voyez bien dans tous
les cas que j'ai évoqué c'est des gens
qui ont besoin d'une aide adaptée qui va
être parfois un peu plus de formation
parfois d'être aidé sur les enfants
parfois donc il faut que l'aide elle
soit quasiment cou humain parce que le
système il est trop il est trop large
c'est du c'est pas du sures il faut du
surmesure et à côté de ça d'autres ils
ont besoin d'être plus responsabilisés
très rapidement parce que je vois qu'il
y a énormément de messages aussi surcune
facilité mais il faut essayer de se dire
les choses il y a beaucoup de messages
sur sur Youtube et sur TikTok on est en
direct sur la question de parcours sup
vaste sujet on a parlé de la question de
la transparence et de de de la pédagogie
et de la transparence sur ces élémentsl
mais un élément qui est assez important
qui est peut-être plus brûlant on va
dire dans dans l'actualité c'est la
question des candidats qui sont en
attente d'affectation alors début
juillet on n pas encore les chiffres là
plus récents début juillet si vous les
avez très bien ils étaient encore 77000
candidats en
ça a baissé ça a baissé je je j'imagine
bien pour autant il y en a et alors là
on on a des tweets qui permettent de le
de le montrer de certains qui qui
réagissent DISM cas de la rentrée
toujours aucune admission sur sur
parcours sup ça date il y a 2 TR jours
c'est a 3 4 jours à 3 jours de la
rentrée 18 refus9 4 V en attente à 4
jours de la rentrée et peut-être en
dernier je vous donner le chiffre à 10
jours de la fin de la phase d'admission
donc d'abord on s'améliore chaque année
euh il reste 2309 candidats sans
proposition et qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
ces jeunes attendez 500 de moins que
l'année dernière ils sont actuellement
pris en charge par des commissions
d'accompagnement de rectorat donc en
fait là pardon de ce terme on les fait à
la main donc dedans parce que vous savez
parcours suip on a ceux qui sortent de
terminal et puis ceux qui se réoriente
dedans on a
1769 bachelièr et
bacheliier et 303 étudiants en
réorientation ils sont sans affectation
aujourd'hui exactement donc là qu'est-ce
qu'on fait c'est les commissions dans
chaque rectoral commission
d'accompagnement qui vont les appeler
pour leur trouver une solution donc
c'est 2000 Fran c'est au cas par cas
pour les milliers d' vous serez tous
appelés par les commissions
d'accompagnement on laissera on laissera
personne tomber on essera de contacter
les trois personnes en question et voir
ce qu'il a non mais enfin dis-moi ça
m'intéresse d'avoir
retour alors après quand je regarde les
choses qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
évidemment on veut mener ça à zéro mais
on a une procédure qui déjà est beaucoup
plus rapide qu'avant en 2018 elle durait
108 jours maintenant on est à 37 jours
bon donc on a des vraies améliorations
après s c'est toujours un stress énorme
pour les 2000 que j'évoque he qui et et
l'enjeu est le même évidemment pour mon
Master alors mon Master pour ceux qui ne
sont pas encore là c'est la même le même
fonctionnement très général pour la
question des masters c'est écrit dans le
dans le nom de la même façon en juillet
dernier 15 % des candidats étaient
encore sans affectation est-ce qu'on a
les chiffres sur les é je pas là vous me
faites une colle mais je si vous
voulez l'enjeu est forcément le le le
même auprès de ces auprès de ces jeunes
et ça me semble important de d'en parler
non mais en tout cas ils seront tous
accompagnés tout le monde sera
accompagné il y aura une solution pour
tout le monde et et là-dessus on dit
tiens et avec après la philosophie que
j'aié voqué tout à l'heure on suiva on
suiva évidemment tout ça dans dans les
prochains dans les prochains jours
dernière dernier élément peut-être qu'on
peut évoquer la question de
l'alimentation j'aurais deux questions
pour terminer peut-être cette cette
interview j'aurais voulu évoquer plein
d'AES sujets mais ça fait déjà quasiment
2 heures qu'on qu'on qu'on parle le
premier sujet sur la question de
l'alimentation c'est la question des
étudiants très rapidement sur ce pointl
euh vous avvez a annoncé lors de la
période du covid 2021 si mes souvenirs
sont bons les repas à 1 € dans les
crouses l'enjeu était assez simple faire
en sorte que les élèves boursiers et
ceux qui en font la demande s'ils sont
en difficulté financière puissent
avoiravoir des repas à 1 € au sein de
ces de ces restaurants universitaires
deux enjeux très rapidement là-dessus
déjà la question de sa prolongation
est-ce que ça va être prolongé et
ensuite une question de mise en place je
me permets de poser la question parce
qu'on a eu beaucoup de retours de
personnes qui étaient encore en attente
qui nét pas boursier mais qui avait fait
la demande qui était en attente
peut-être faute de personnel ou
simplement de de de retour pour
bénéficier de ces aides là est-ce
qu'elles vont être prolongées c'est
repart à 1 € pour les boursiers et pour
les personnes dans les besoins et
comment est-ce que tout cela va va
évoluerord l'alimentation des jeunes
c'est un point sur lequel on a essayer
de faire d'énormes efforts le petit déj
à l'école c'est un point fondamental la
cantine à 1 € on a accompag pour ceux
qui ont des grantines ouais mais non
mais pour les écoles et les les collèges
lycées c'est un point fondamental on a
on a 4000 commune je crois qu'il sont
engagé dans ce programme et je remercie
les mères enfin c'est l'État qui les
aide et qui contribue et c'est une
petite révolution pour qu'on ait des
enfants qui mangent bien et vous avez
dit on a pris ce dispositif d'exception
pendant le covid là on l' reciblé sur
les boursiers donc c'est sur les tous
les élèves boursiers continueront à
avoir le repain 1 euro très clair une
dernière question que je voulais poser
qui est dans l'actualité tristement si
je me permettre le terme dans dans
l'actualité c'est la question des
rissaus du cœur c'est une question plus
large mais on sait qu'il y a énormément
d'étudiants de jeunes même plus
généralement
qui et bien font la queue et et et pour
avoir de l'alimentation gratuitement
devant les les restos du cœur au total
150000 personnes pourraient être
affectées par bien les enjeux les
difficultés financières qu'ont
l'organisation et l'association les
restau du cœur aujourd'hui alors Aurore
berger la ministre des Solidarités a
déjà annoncé sur TF1 lors du 20h une
aide supplémentaire de 15 million
d'euros mais selon le président des
Restos du cœur 100 millions étaient déjà
prévu donc c'est 5 millions
supplémentaires qui ont été ajoutés les
restéau du cœur estiment avoir besoin
d'au moins 35 millions d'euros qu'est-ce
que vous dites déjà au resto du cœur non
d'abord les restos du cœur sont une
association quiis des décennies fait un
travail
absolument colossal et qui
pour beaucoup de gens trop est un est un
soutien indispensable donc dans le
contexte il y a cette tension elle est
claire elle est elle est fondamentale
donc on va être là donc la ministre a
annoncé une augmentation de la
subvention qui était prévu et non et non
confirmé donc elle a à la fois confirmé
et augmenté et notre objectif c'est de
rassembler autour de nous euh aussi de
la solidarité privée parce que je pense
que c'est la responsabilité de tous et
tous j'ai vu que des premiers groupes
avaient annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il venait
au côté du gouvernement pour donner et
d'obtenir les 35 millions donc c'est
simple euh engagement de l'État avec
l'argent du contribuable et Don privé
pour qu'on puisse obtenir ces 35
millions dans les dans les semaines qui
viennent et je remercie tous les groupes
privés qui accompagne le gouvernement
dans cet effort supplémentaire on doit
le faire on suivra tout ça dans les dans
les prochains jours ça va faire
quasiment 2 heures qu'on qu'on discute
de discute qu'on a des des échanges sur
tous ces ces sujets là merci beaucoup
vous président d'avoir d'avoir pris le
temps d'échanger sur tous ces sujets je
me permets de le dire dès maintenant
d'avance à tous ceux dans les
commentaires que ce soit en live ou que
ce soit en diffusion c'est toujours un
exercice qui est pas évident parce que
on a un temps limité alors long là mais
qui reste limité énormément de sujets
qu'on aimerait couvrir on aurait pu
développer sur la question de parcours
sup sur la question évidment tout un tas
de sujets y compris des sujets
d'ailleurs qui concernent les jeunes
mais pas directement entre guillemets la
question des retraites on aurait pu
revenir revenir dessus on a fait un
choix la question du handicap aussi on a
fait un choix de se concentrer sur
certains sujets notamment des sujets
économiques des sujets de santé mental
des sujets environnementaux et d'essayer
de d'y voir plus clair sur tous ces ces
sujets là merci encore monsieur le
Président d'avoir accepté ce échange
aujourd'hui au passage pour tous ceux
qui qui sont encore sur cette vidéo là
on postera dans dans la soirée je pense
un résumé des différentes des
différentes annonces ou des éléments qui
ont été qui ont été dits lors de cette
cette vidéo et puis on continuera à
suivre l'actualité vous le savez de
toute façon sur nos autres réseaux merci
encore monsieur le Président pour votre
temps merci à vous pour votre confiance
merci à toute l'équipe aussi qui est
derrière cette cette interview C
beaucoup travaill avec mon équipe de
journalistes il y a beaucoup de travail
il fait très chaud je pense que ça s'est
senti merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et puis à bientôt merci
beaucoup merci à vous et merci aux
équipes merci
beaucoup
[Musique]